[music]
Good morning. [music]
Hey, [music]
hey, hey.
[music]
Heat. Heat.
[music and bell]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Hey, Heat.
>> [music]
>> Why you baby?
[music]
Hey, hey, hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> I'm ready on you, Jose. [music]
>> [music]
>> streets. [music]
Wall Streetion
[music]
baby
off.
[music] We made a million in the day.
Tell me how we go from
[music]
stocks for that like selling work in
that [music and singing]
money secure. I got in, I got out.
Keeping all glory to God. Hold up. This
ain't me. Tell [music] me how we went
from trapping topping.
Last [singing] week I told invested to
[music] the Kansas City. Golden rule to
invest and make that money while you
sleep. They say trapper perfect [music]
sleep. I'm gone.
What's good? What's good? What's good,
family? It's your boy, the Wall Street
Trapper, and welcome to another episode
of Trapping Tuesdays, man.
All right, man. So, you know, before we
get started, man, I definitely want to
tell each and every one of y'all. Thank
y'all, man. We 200 plus episodes in
because of y'all looking for 200 more.
Listen, we want to tell every last one
of y'all, man. Without y'all, there is
no us, man. Y'all give us purpose. Y'all
give us reason. Y'all give us just
everything. We dedicated. We appreciate
the uh reposts on Instagram, the reposts
on YouTube, the comments, you know,
watching us in the crib, watching us at
work, watching us in the kitchen,
watching us while you watching your
kids, watching us in the bedroom. We
just want to tell y'all, man, we
appreciate y'all. We are nothing without
y'all. So, from myself and the team,
thank y'all so much. You heard me.
All right, man. So, I was thinking about
something as I was coming here today
and I I I want everybody to know that
there is a subscription to your success.
I'm I'mma I'mma start right there so we
can lay the foundation early, right? And
and it doesn't always cost you money.
It will cost you comfort.
Sometimes it will cost you sleep.
Sometimes it will cost you money.
Sometimes it will cost you the thing you
don't want to sacrifice. Sometimes it
will cost you loneliness. Sometimes it
will cost you boredom.
There is a subscription to your success.
And most people, watch this y'all, most
people won't. their payment method will
decline because they want to pay for a
life of comfort through lack of
discipline.
>> Okay? Like most people want to get a
life of comfort where you can take the
trips, where you can have your bills on
autopay, where you can travel around the
world, where you can get out the bed
whenever you want. But in order to get
to a life of comfort, you must have
discipline. And so most people don't
understand that success must be paid for
every single day and it's never half
off.
[music] The price of success actually
can increase like they increase what it
cost annually. Like one season of your
life it'll cost you you know just money.
First season of your life is going to
cost you money cuz you ain't got it. So,
it's going to cost it's going to cost
the commitment to put everything in to
achieve it. And and then in the next
season of your life, it's going to cost
you something else. Like the next season
of your life, it may cost you your peace
cuz you can't sleep at night because
everything that you want is in your head
and it's and I want to do this and I
want to do that and I don't know how to
do this and I don't know how to do this
and I need this person, I need that
person and there's multiple attacks
coming. In one season it cost money. In
one season it cost peace and in in
another season
may cause you loneliness.
Now you got to operate by yourself. You
got to disassociate.
You you you you got to tell your homies,
Abra ain't coming,
right? You you you you may spend more
time working than you do with your kids.
And it's the struggle to find balance.
Like every season of your life, the
subscription cost a little bit more.
Because if the price stayed the same,
you wouldn't appreciate it.
The price of success stayed the same,
Because if you're a millionaire and it
cost you a little money, then the money
is not the thing.
But if all you got is time and and it's
costing you time, then so so every
season of your life that you are after
success, the subscription to success
will cost more.
[music]
Now, here's the thing. Most people
think, you know, the trading will get
them to success. And some people think
it's it's the business that will get
them to success. Some people think it's
the real estate that's going to get them
to success. But we don't really
understand that it's the discipline that
is always the down payment.
It's the discipline to success that is
always the down payment.
It's the willingness to sacrifice
[music]
again and again and again and again
until sacrifice becomes [music] a part
of your diet
until sacrifice becomes a part of your
routine.
A lot of times we try to negotiate the
necessary. [music]
We we are going to a place that we have
never been. And so I remember like I
remember I went out the country one time
and and I thought about it and I was
like damn I don't got no cash.
Immediately I said, "Okay, what?" Like
and I realized that because I love the
AAX car so much. But I had to realize
something too. Everywhere don't take
Amex.
Everywhere don't take. So I don't got no
cash on me. Everywhere don't take Amex.
Now watch this. And I left my Chase card
at the crib cuz I had change wallet.
So now I'm in a aqua situation. I'm out
the country, no cash. And now I got to
hope that everybody everywhere I go
takes this Apex card.
So I go to the first place, they like,
"Y'all take Amex?" They're like, "Yeah,
we take Amex."
Ah.
So I go to another place, say, "You
Apex?" They say, "Yeah, we take Apex."
So now on the whole trip, I just want to
go to those two places.
I'm saying that because on your journey,
there's a form of comfort that you'll
get. [snorts and music] There's a form
of familiarity that you'll get. Like me
just looking at I'm like, "Yo, I got the
wallet. I'm good." And I ain't check.
You so comfortable. You ain't checking.
You know you want to go to this
destination. Watch me here. Watch me
here. You want to go to a new
destination, but you want to keep some
of the old stuff with you.
But watch this. You forget the
essentials.
You forget to check what's needed on the
next level. You forget to check what's
needed in the next destination. Because
where you going next may not accept what
you come from.
Where you going next may not accept the
payment method that you used before.
That's it. That's it. The next
destination that you go to may not
accept. Let me let me break let me get
cool [music] with this because I don't
want to get too excited, right? Like
where you going next may not accept,
watch this, the old payment method. So
you have to figure out what it is that
they accepted. Now watch me here.
The fear of figuring it out also rides
with the fear of getting declined.
Your fear of getting declined is
actually what keeps you going. Keeps you
from going. Let me say that again. Your
fear of getting declined [music] is what
kept me at the two places. I didn't want
to go nowhere else cuz I don't want to
press my luck.
I want to go where safe at. I'm out the
country. I don't want to explore. I'm
sticking to room service and these two
places cuz I don't want to get declined.
[music]
So, I didn't have the experience that I
wanted to have.
[music] I had the two AMX cars and my
passport, no cash. Left my Chase card at
home.
I stuck what to what was comfortable.
I didn't veer off. And you like try,
what's that got to do with what I'm
trying to go? Your fear of failure is
[music] what's keeping you from going to
the next level.
Your fear of what happens on the other
side of that door. You [music] feel like
you ill equipped because you left
everything at home.
There's a subscription to success. One
of them is discipline and one of them is
courage.
It's the ability to go into the unknown,
not fearing failure, but embracing it.
It's saying, I'm willing to go into this
place leaving the things behind that I
thought I needed and figuring out what's
needed for me as I get there.
>> [music]
>> Let me make this make sense a little bit
more.
I bought this building not knowing a god
dog on thing about real estate.
I I I had no idea. I had no clue about
real estate. As a matter of fact, I had
just purchased my first home to live in.
But the goal was to get a 50,000t
building.
And I remember I had these this vision
and I had this idea of like this what I
want to do and this I want to do and $4
million later I still ain't all the way
where I want to be at.
So So in this case, [music] money isn't
the issue. Money isn't the payment
needed here.
Money money isn't the required payment.
It's endorsed.
Can you endure?
Can you navigate everything that it
takes? Because the learning curve is
what hurts most people.
You cannot let what you don't know be an
excuse for you not to go where you want
to go. All right, let me say that again.
Right, let me say that again. Like, you
cannot let what you don't know be an
excuse [music] of why you don't achieve
the things that in your heart you know
you can achieve. So, you keep saying, "I
don't know how." And somebody else is
saying, "I'mma figure it out." There's
the difference. In my mind, I just keep
saying, "I'mma figure it out no matter
what comes my way." Has it been easy?
Hell no. Has it been hard? Hell yes.
Will it get harder? Hell yes. But guess
what? I'mma figure it out.
The subscription to success changes
payment methods in every season.
And this season may be I just want to
save $1,000.
I want to save $10,000 [music]
in the next season. It may be what does
it take for me to buy my first rental
property
in the next season. It may be what does
it take for me to get [music] better at
my taxes?
In the next season, it may be what does
it look like for me to pass my [music]
wealth down?
In the next season, it may be how do I
start another business? In the next
season, it may be how do I lead my
family? In the next season, it may be
how do I give my kids a life that I
never had, but also install something in
them that wasn't installed in me. And
the next season, every season requires
something different. And the minute you
decide you don't want to pay it is the
minute they revoke your access.
The minute you decide you don't want to
pay it, it says access denied.
The subscription is renewed annually. We
go through seasons and every seasons
will require a different action but also
a different version of you. [music]
In one season you may be willing to
watch Housewives of Atlanta. The next
season you willing to watch CNBC. The
next season now you watching document on
people how they became successful. The
next season you locked all the way in on
God. So that not only does the
subscription price change, watch this,
the lens at which you view the movie
change.
Man, I think they missing what I'm
saying, bro. I don't think y'all get
what I'm saying. Like for every you
cannot go into the season looking at it
the same way you looked at the last
season. So, a couple weeks ago, we
talked about using experiences from the
past to help navigate us in the future,
but that can only go so far. We need
future experiences to get us through the
future.
We need future experiences. Meaning,
what will I experience in the future
that's going to give me more data to get
me through the next phase of this thing?
Success.
Everybody say they want it. And if I ask
you right now, yo, what is your freedom
mean to you? If I ask you right now,
what does success mean to you? You'll
take the easy way out and say it's
priceless.
Cuz you ain't bold enough to put a
number on it. Cuz when you put a number
on it, now you got to take ownership of
it. When you put a number on it, now you
got to commit to it. And the number that
you put on it may may sound good on
paper, but it may be too big for your
actions.
It may be too big for your commitment.
So it's easy for you to say, "Oh, it's
priceless.
Oh, it it it means everything to me."
You taking the easy way out. Put a
number on it. I dare you.
Put a number on it that scares you.
Matter of fact, put a number on it that
petrifies you.
put a number on it that make you
uncomfortable when you close your eyes
and you work na day in [music] and day
out to achieve it. It's not the number
is but what the number requires you to
be.
There's a version of me that's standing
you right here
that I dreamed about this 5 years ago.
>> [music]
>> I remember when we first got into the
got dog on building,
as soon as I walked in the 6,000 square
feet, [music] I said, "Hey, this ain't
big enough."
The minute I walked into it, [music]
2022,
I walked into the building, I said,
"This ain't big enough."
I outgrew it the minute I walked in it.
Some of y'all have put a number down,
you outgrow it as soon as you wrote it
on the paper.
Soon as you wrote it down, you knew you
was bigger than it,
but you'll fight for mediocrity.
You'll fight for the mediocrity because
[music] you scared of what the
subscription going to cost you.
You'll fight for the mediocrity because
you scared of the price of the
subscription and what it's going to cost
you.
[music]
instead of hanging around or being
around people that require you
to increase your value.
When the last time you did a appraisal
on your dreams?
on the things that you want to
accomplish?
When the last time you did a appraisal
on your commitment?
When the last time you did an appraisal
on your discipline?
on your spiritual growth?
When the last time you did an appraisal
on you?
When the last time you did that?
Because all that's wrapped up into that
subscription.
It's not just a price. It's not just a
dollar amount
cuz every year that subscription going
to increase
and every year you got to be willing to
say
I want to renew it.
Every year you got to be willing to say
I want to go further.
Or will you say this subscription cost
me too much?
I'mma look for a fire stick.
Some of y'all looking, what's the cheat
code trap? What's the [music] cheat code
trap? I'm going to give you a newslet.
Ain't none.
There is none. commitment, dedication,
discipline, losses.
I told somebody the other day and it was
was crazy, Jose. I said,
"Sometimes something got to get taken
away from you for you [music] to
appreciate how much it is. You got to
lose something
for you to appreciate it." And and they
like, "Man, what you mean by that?" I
said, "Bro,
what led me to that was they asked me if
I could change anything about my life."
They like, "Crap, if you could change
anything about your life, like
everything that happened to you, going
to prison, being home, uh, would you
change anything about it?" I said, "Hell
no." Because every version of what I've
been through helped me become the person
I am today. It was like, even the 10
years in prison, I said, "I wouldn't
take back a date.
I wouldn't take back a year. They was
like, "What?" I said, "For if I took
away the five, if I took five off the
10, there's things that happened during
the five that helped me evolve."
The first five, I was on a certain
level. The last five, I was like, "Ah,
it's different. I saw the world
different. I evolved
from from 16 to 21, I was a different
person. From 21 to 26, I had done
evolved."
Well, Trap, you ain't really need to do
that in jail. It was some things that I
learned in jail that prepared for me
when I came home.
So, I said to him, I said,
"Sometimes we don't appreciate our
freedom till it's took it away from us."
It's like, I said, "I said, I'm going to
give you an example.
How many times have you been sick? Let's
say you got to saw through.
You don't appreciate drinking water as
much as you need to unless you got a
sore throat.
Like you don't care about drinking the
water. You got man drink. We got sore
throat. I just need some water.
Sometimes you don't appreciate it till
it's taken away from you.
That's a subscription to success.
And in [music] every season, it's going
to cost you something different.
And the biggest question is, are you
going to pay for it
or are you going to complain?
Are you going to renew the subscription
or you going to deny it?
It's your boy, the Wall Street Traffic
Man, episode 203, the subscription to
[music] success. Let's go, y'all.
Man, I think I had an orange, bro.
I think I had an orange. Anyway, what's
up, bro?
>> How you feeling, man?
>> Man, I see you on one today.
>> Am I,
>> dog? People in the joint like, "Bro, he
on one today."
>> Am I on one?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That was
>> I don't know, bro.
>> That was
>> Good. And like it had me thinking like
my wife got me cancelling subscriptions
right now as we speak, but it's a couple
of my need.
>> We know Ash don't play about.
>> A couple of my need. I got to pay the
increase cuz
>> you know you got to you got to listen.
>> It ain't easy. It ain't cheap.
>> Yeah.
>> You got to pay it.
>> Or or
do you
get rid of the subscription? Hey
Man, gota got to wait.
>> You always got a choice,
>> dog. When you said the water joint.
>> Oh, bro.
>> Listen, you got to think. First off, my
voice is sexy as a mother right now,
bro. Come on. Nothing.
Miss Amy, my voice ain't sexy.
Come on now. 101.9 WL LU N. Wash. She
looks like us now. That's your boy Jose.
We going to slow it down tonight for
you.
>> Come on. It's the love talking slow jams
voice. [snorts]
>> I don't know what I caught from that
mastermind though, but I ain't been this
sick this long since co. You know what
I'm saying? But we back masked up. You
know what I'm saying? We here. Look.
See, they like, "Come on, Jose. We
getting it." First off, also I need
everybody to share this out. Hit the
like button. YouTube was slipping on our
notifications today and I got flushed
early for for YouTube a sending out the
notifications. But we still here.
>> We still here.
>> Slipping, dog.
>> We still good. You know what I'm saying?
They do updates and they don't tell me.
[laughter] But we still we still here.
>> You know what I'm saying? Share this
thing out. [groaning]
>> How you feeling, bro? Hey, I'm about at
80%, bro.
>> Say, bro,
I think this last week I just been I
don't know, bro. I've been uh
I ain't been in my
>> I already know you ain't been in your
>> Yeah, bro.
>> And I let you breathe a lot. I' been
like my dog going through whatever he
got. You know what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, bro. I've been I've been feeling a
little heavy a little bit, dog.
>> Mhm. I feel
>> I've been feeling a little heavy a
little bit. I don't know what it is,
bro.
>> That That's the worst part when you just
don't know exactly what that thing is.
>> Yeah, I've been feeling a little heavy,
dog. Uh I've been just trying to
navigate it. You know what I'm saying?
But I've been feeling a little heavy,
bro. And I think I got a
>> uh
I've been I started Bible study with
Pastor Don one last night. He gave me
some heavy game last night with that.
But uh
I don't know, bro. I just been a little
heavy this last week.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying? I've been a
little heavy, bro. So,
>> um even when I've been trying to work,
I've been I've been just, you know, I
don't know, man. I just been
>> I don't know. Not focused.
>> Mhm.
>> Kind of just
>> I mean, you're doing the right thing.
Like we're getting the Bible, getting to
the gym. I' been back.
>> You got baby girl still with you?
>> Even a day I I was uh I was on the phone
with Meta all day, but then I was like,
man, I ain't go to the gym. Let me go.
So, I went in the garage
and did some um Emit. What's good,
family? Here go my subscription. Emit,
what's good, family?
Um,
yeah, man. I just been a little heavy
this week, bro. You know what I'm
saying? I'm taking my daughter taking my
daughter on our first trip,
uh, our our annual summer trip. So, I
usually take her on a trip before she go
back to school.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'mma take her on a trip. Um,
>> I just been a little heavy, bro. My mom
start hitting me up, man. My mom about
to get baptized.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that was real cool. That [snorts]
was real cool, bro. But I just been a
little I don't know, bro. I've been a
little heavy, bro. Even when I get my
IVs, they usually like give me a little
pop. I just been That's why I know it's
like something spiritual on me. You know
what I'm saying? something I gotta I
gotta lock in with the big homie. I
think he trying to tell me something or
he want me to be aware or something or
>> you know what I'm saying?
>> Sometimes we got to sit and just listen.
>> I think that's where I'm at right now,
bro. Like I just want to sit down.
>> You know what I'm saying? I just want to
chill. I don't really want to do too
much. Uh but yeah, man. That's just
where I've been, bro.
>> Cuz what? It's not even a big storm or
nothing either. It's just like
>> Huh?
>> No, it ain't. It ain't, bro. It's not
even a storm. like I'm going through it
or nothing. It's just like
>> that push of teeth.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying? It's one
of them moments, bro. I just uh
>> I don't know, man.
>> I say this when you get back on the
other side. This this is what I tell me.
When you get back on the other side,
like you just said, like I need to
remember even this feeling like where
you at right now. So when I get back on
the other side, it kind of gives you
another level of gratitude. That's why
that's why I said like this was a
perfect,
>> you know, title because like every seat
you got to think, bro, I just come from
Italy. This my dream vacation.
>> I'm I'm I'm I'm on cloud nine.
>> Mhm.
>> You know what I'm saying? Like I'm in
that mode. I'm I'm out there like I'm
about to go back home and go crazy.
>> Yeah.
>> Like I'm feeling good. I'm at I'm at I'm
at peak performance. Actually, this has
been the first time that you hit the
incline and came back and
>> Yeah.
>> Like literally this the first
>> like I'm telling you, bro.
>> Once I hit pump, I'm like like I hit and
I'm like I I'm like, damn. Why am I feel
like I'm
>> So I just got to get through it, man.
I'm doing a little Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Anyway,
>> let's get it. Let's get it.
>> It's a season.
>> Yeah.
>> You got to you got to you got to embrace
every season, bro. And here's the thing
that I will say like
when I say my prayers when I get in
seasons like this, I never pray for the
season to be over.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I always pray that I get stronger and
better and that I get out of it what I'm
supposed to get out of it.
>> Yeah.
>> Feel what I'm saying? Like I never
people like, man, I just can't wait to
be over. I never go through it like that
cuz I'mma miss something.
>> Yep.
>> Right.
>> Like you said, that five years it taught
you something in this. was like, "All
right, like what what what do I what
what am I supposed to get out of this
season?" You know what I'm saying? What
is it like? What am I supposed to get
out of it? How do I get better?
>> How do I get stronger?
Uh and so, so it can prepare me for it
next. And I think we look at it when we
look at our life, we got to always look
at our life like that. Like, well, you
know, I learned this from Inky. I think
he said some it was it's a verse in the
Bible that talks about that when he said
uh
you know the verse man damn
I'm having a brain fog right here where
it's uh
let me get on my phone right
>> you going to look it up
>> I got to say it I usually know it off
top my head but I got to look it up this
time. Uh what
blue said trap you mimicking the semi
stocks? They had a pullback reset
[laughter]
for the bigger runner up. You know what
I'm saying?
>> Uh
>> the Trappers be knowing.
Somebody asks is the IG pay situation? I
mean it's you got to think it's
different pieces and different
ingredients that go into the gumbo to
create.
>> There you go. James 1 2-4 consider joy
brothers and sisters whenever you face
trials of many kinds because you know
that testing of your faith produces
perseverance that's the one
>> and go down to 12. Go down to 12. You
can't never forget. You got to skip down
to 12.
>> You got to say I don't know it. I just
wrote I just came up right here. It just
pulled up. What 12 say?
>> Shoot. I don't know.
>> Let me see. How you going to tell me go
to 12? N
>> cuz I just know I got to always but I
got to put 12 with it.
>> Let me see.
>> I'm having a brain fart too. I'm at 80%
bro.
Let me see. I got you. I got you. I got
you.
I got you. Blessed is the man that
endureth temptation when he is tried. He
shall receive the crown of life which
the Lord hath promised to them that he
loved.
>> Let no man say that he is tempted. I am
tempted of God. For God cannot be
tempted with evil, neither tempted he
any man. But every man is tempted when
he is drawn away from his own lust. Now
where where that come from, Jose?
>> Well, see
>> that had nothing to do with I had going
on.
>> Oh, no, no, no. But you when you hit
that that that two through four,
whatever, you got to hit that 12 joint
that that thing.
>> You be fighting lust, dog.
>> Huh? You be fighting lust? Fighting
what? Lust. Nah. Not no more. [laughter]
>> Not no more.
>> Well, answer that like a married man.
Yeah, I know. Huh?
>> That boy say huh?
>> Shoot.
>> They had to think about that. Huh?
>> Hey, see that hunt?
>> You lost that.
>> I heard it.
>> Your wife every morning. Every day.
Every day.
>> That hot mean I heard it. Let me get
this answer right here. [laughter]
>> Shoo. Shy.
[laughter]
>> Shoo. Play that no more.
>> Hey. Hey.
>> Playing under control.
>> I said, "Look, you be dealing with us."
Huh? [laughter]
I said you be dealing with us, huh?
>> No, that wasn't that. That was cuz I
couldn't hear you.
>> Huh?
>> Oh, everybody laughing too much. See
what we doing? I'm about to fry each and
>> I be dealing with what?
>> Oh, no. Not at all.
>> Hell no. Trap.
[laughter]
[screaming]
>> Hey, call that boy Twinkle. He was
[laughter]
that ball was quick on it, huh,
>> buddy?
>> I said you be doing, huh? [laughter]
>> What you say?
>> All bad.
>> You got left all bad, huh?
God bless.
>> Oh, bless all.
>> What you say, partner? [laughter]
>> You got left all bad, huh?
>> You got left all bad in ba, huh?
>> That jo was crazy. Look like I left look
like I got left all bad and bougie. My
dog answered that.
>> Frank, do I do I look like I'm dealing
with lust?
>> [__] [laughter] Huh?
>> Lust. Huh?
>> Nah. Deal with that. Next question.
[laughter]
>> She ain't on here right now. Hope.
>> Well, that's her argument for three
months now. Who you be lusting behind?
She already checking them bank account
now. She about to go through that IG.
>> She got to go. She got to go. She got to
go. I said, Usha, she got to go. I said,
she in the choir. She got to go.
>> She in the [laughter] choir.
See,
>> she quiet. She got to go.
>> Look, there she go.
>> There she go. It's all [laughter]
[screaming]
>> I love Ash, man. I love Ash, man.
[laughter] I love Ash. I love Ash. All
right, Jose. What we got? Let's shout
out our people right quick, man.
Uh, let's shout out our people, man. Be
easy 216, I see you. Chopper Fellas, I
see you. Tomorrow Buchanan, I see you.
Uh, Master Student Production, I see
you. Certified Travel for Life, I see
you. Ashley Bennett,
>> chill. Don't forget the Bennett,
>> love. He will, I see you, man. Tory
Simmons, I see you. DoubleR, I see you.
Ashley, no love, see you. Stage two
trader, I see you. Brian Hawk 23, I see
you. Uh,
Germaine Chase, I see you. I am TC, I
see you. Jerome Kinsey, I see you.
Blakes 529 investor, I see [music] you.
Blue field, I see you. Favon, I see you.
Uh, Baby Axel Ride, I see you, Bud.
What's up, Bud? I ain't seen my dog in a
minute, man. I see you. Nathan Nathan
Higgins, I see you. B. Walsh, I see you.
Nate the Great. What's good, brother? Me
and my dog Nate been in the trenches.
We've been fighting with these tech
stars. You heard me? Um,
let's see. Uh,
Sir James, I see you. Blue Fire, I see
you. Uh 98 Rosafarium, I see you. Uh th
Darthy, damn, your name went too fast.
Jerome Kinson, KPI, I see you. Sean
Pipe, I see you.
>> Char Nicole, I hope I said that right. I
see you.
Uh
Tony Gold 410, I see you. The vault
Bolina, what's the B? I [music] see you,
Shorty. First gen mill first gen
millionaire I see you
Carolina blue what's good my guy soul 23
I see you [music]
Runch Nation I see you Doug Perry I see
you Will Mack I see you go get it I see
you KB Mississippi Trapper I see you
Shawn Pipe I said that already Larry
Morgan I see you [music] do Bush I see
you uh KB Mississippi Trapper I see you
Joel Blake I see you Boogie Down 502 I
see you
leap man shad shad I see you
shameless on wall street I see you
they going fast
[music] real fast uh tomorrow Sutton I
see you
fur LLC I see you nappy Turps, I see
you. Eric, Dan, you went fast, but you
know I see you. Eric OG64,
I see you. Anthony Sneed, I see you,
family. Shazam X, there you go, fam. I
see you, brother.
The Jay Kid, I see you. What up, Trap?
Jerry Scott 7406, I see you, fam.
[music]
All right, let's get to our Let's get to
our show, man. Let's get to our show.
>> Boy got the yawn and everything.
>> Got a nice little yarn, bro.
>> Like that. Good. Good. When the last
time you had the IV?
>> Saturday.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Had Miss Cheryl come through, man. Hit
me with the IV.
>> Yeah.
>> Hit me with the IV. Hit me with the NAD.
>> Mhm.
>> I had to stick myself.
>> Yeah. Cuz I had to do a uh I had did a
YouTube live.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And I didn't want her to stick me on the
live.
>> [snorts]
>> So she gave me the IV, but I didn't want
her to stick me on the live.
>> Wait, so you stabbed yourself on the
live?
>> No, no, I waited after the live, but I
wait till the next morning. I ain't
going to lie, man. Cheryl leader was
about this long, bro. I was like, golly,
that would go.
>> Yeah, I don't think I could do my own,
>> man. I had to And it's in the hip.
>> In the hip, cuz I just had to do like
that.
[laughter]
>> I end up hitting a hip nerve or
something. Look, the alcohol pad was
like one, two, three.
>> Lord, today nah.
>> Not I said Jose. Not I.
>> I don't even look when they take blood.
Look.
>> I got all these tattoos, man. I wasn't
tripping on that, man.
>> Oh, you know I'm butt ball naked.
>> Got my Patreon family in the building,
man. I had to tell my family today. All
my Patreon family, let me tell y'all
something right quick, too, man. I
apologize for the last couple days, man.
I've been locked in on that situation I
told y'all about and I really wasn't
able to be in a group like that. So, I
ap I want to apologize for my people and
my Travis Anonymous people. Man, my last
two days I really just been this
situation had a lot of my attention. Um,
and so I wasn't I've been I haven't been
active in my group the last couple days.
I'll just apologize for that, man.
There's no reason for that, but you
know, it happened. So, let's get to it,
man. I have to send an email out too,
dog. So, I need you to give me a second
on that.
All right, let's go.
I am a certified Wall Street trapper.
I'm confident in my ability to make
great investments. The stock market is a
machine that prints money, and I'm more
than capable of operating this machine.
Not only would I free myself, but my
family will eat for a lifetime based on
the information I apply today.
I'm a money maker and a wealth builder.
Today I break all the chains that anchor
me to that poverty mindset. My ancestors
will smile now because I've turned our
last name into an asset. My family's
purchasing power will increase
indefinitely. Today, I make the
declaration that no longer will I be a
slave to money. No longer will a
generation behind me and Harry lack. No
longer will I submit to selling my time
for money. I am a first generation
millionaire. I am the architect of my
family's legacy. I am a certified Wall
Street trapper and Wall Street looks
like us now.
Let's go, man.
I got an idea, dog. Bro, I'm going to go
on tour,
[laughter]
but Miss Janet say we can't go to the
beginning of next year.
>> Okay.
>> So, we got to wait.
>> You know me, bro.
>> That to was a monster. I be want to act
now.
>> I know that [laughter]
that is your that is your MMO.
>> Yeah, I ain't mad at it.
>> I be wanting to go.
>> I be want to go.
>> Yeah, that was a that was a monster.
>> I be wanting to go.
>> We loaded up the truck. The truck.
>> Load up the truck,
>> dog. We had everything.
>> I even drove the truck.
>> Matter of fact, everything that we did
for the show, load them.
>> Load it up
>> the desk. I think the go I think I think
this time though I don't want to do a
trapping Tuesday,
>> right?
>> I think that's what made it like super
long
cuz we like we did like a in we did like
a education a trapping Tuesday and then
the education.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. That was a and you know the show
start at 7.
>> That was a four. They was leaving out at
like what 11.
>> Yeah.
>> Cali was all right cuz you know what I'm
saying it's early in the day.
Yeah. Cali was Cali started at what?
Five
>> about that. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I think I want to do I think I want
to do like four or five cities, dog.
Do something like four or five cities.
>> What's the premise like? What's the
where they walk? You know how when I
always go to say what's that practical
thing? What's that thing they should be
walking away with,
>> [__] Trap.
>> Trapping. [laughter]
Trapping, [__]
Yeah, I want to
>> I think it's time, bro. Like, it's been
too long.
>> Mhm.
>> It's been too long, bro. Like,
>> actually, that was epic. We had
>> every year we need to go on tour, dog.
>> We had Ross.
>> Ross. Mostly it was just me.
>> Yeah.
>> For five for seven cities, it was me.
>> We just did Ross in 18 New Orleans.
>> Mhm.
>> But you got to think, bro, that was
2020. What? Two.
Yeah, bro.
>> I know we could do like 800 people a
city now.
>> Yeah,
>> we done got we done grew more. That was
2022, bro.
>> It's 2026.
>> I'm with it. Definitely. If we ain't
doing quoteunquote trapping Tuesday,
that's an easier lift.
It's a lot to try to run a lot.
>> Yeah, cuz like we ain't doing no
trapping Tuesday. It's just a It's a 2
hour, three hour show.
>> Yeah, that'd be epic.
>> Two hour show at least.
>> Yeah,
>> we do like an interview.
>> We could do like We can make it fun.
Like we can do like an interview,
>> a s We can do like a session. We do like
an intro session.
>> Do like an interview session. Then we do
like a game session
>> and then we do a teaching session to
close.
>> I'm with it.
>> Let me see that. That'll be good. Like
we could do like a let me see a opening
session.
Boom. Then we can do like a
lesson.
Then we could do a interview.
Then we can have a speaker come in each
city outside of me.
And then we close with a lesson. So I
can say the first lesson is buy and
hold.
Then we do an interview. Then we do a
speaker. And then the last session we
close with options.
That's the That's the layout right
there. That's the layout right there.
>> That's good.
>> That's the layout. That's the layout.
>> Got an opening. We do a a a buying hole
session. Then we do this interview
session. Then we do and then the
interview session is we get somebody in
every city to interview. We get somebody
different in every I got a I got a bag
that's big enough to and I don't mean
cash bag meaning my relationship bag big
enough to interview somebody in each
city.
You feel what I'm saying?
>> I like that a lot. Again, my whole thing
if we ain't doing it live, bro, we can
go crazy.
>> Yeah, we doing it live.
>> No, I mean live streaming.
>> We doing it live. We going to Yeah, we
not doing live stream. [laughter]
>> And even if we do live stream, it's
different than hard time cuz you know
it's a specific thing we got to do for
Tuesdays. You know what I'm saying? So
we was literally working around that
where
>> we did flush it a flip.
>> Flush it a flip was fine.
>> We could bring that back.
>> Yeah, that was
>> like we could curate a go a dope show,
dog.
>> Yeah.
Yeah,
>> we can curate a dope show cuz
>> Yeah. 98% they like, "Yo, let's get it."
You know, I put the poll out there.
>> My only thing is if we do the show in
Atlanta, do we do it here?
>> H we go to like Buckhead Theater or
something?
>> Yeah. Eight.
>> No, we can't get eight. [laughter]
>> Eight. Eight.
>> I think we could do like New Orleans
again. Gotta do Houston.
Gotta do the A. Gotta do New York. Gotta
do them fit.
>> Yeah.
>> Then I think we go to gotta go somewhere
on the west coast. We did LA last time.
So do we do Oakland?
Do we do we do got to be like Oakland or
LA? Got to be Oakland or LA.
>> Got to be Oakland or LA. But that's two
different version of Cali.
>> That's the Bay. You know what I'm
saying? Then you got to go somewhere
else. You got to go somewhere else in
the Midwest or do you go St. Louis?
Do you go Chicago?
>> Chicago always open,
>> right? Do you do St. Louis? Do Chicago?
Then you got to come back in that other
area where you got the Carolas.
So do you hit the Carolas, the Virginia,
the DC that you got to you got to
>> the Charlotte.
>> I like that.
>> You know what I'm saying? You got that
DC, you got that Charlotte, you got that
Carolina, that Virginia. That's an area
right there.
>> Yeah. We kind of got to touch the
Philly,
>> right? But if you in there, then you got
to what you do, you do New York. New
York, you got that tri state. But what
about the people, right? You know what
I'm saying? So if you do New York, you
can do Baltimore, Philly. Like what does
that look like? Then you go to the other
side. Like I mean, I'm not going to go
to Idaho. I don't got nobody there.
>> You got anybody in the zona, Arizona?
They better catch the Cali show.
So where we going at? You feel me? So
you get you get New Orleans, you get
Houston, you get Atlanta, you get NY.
That's your four majors. I got to go
there. And then you go Cali, but you
don't know where. You go Oakland or you
go LA. That's a that's a toss up.
>> They they still in here asking about
London.
>> My my CFO said we got to wait till next
year [laughter]
cuz London cost.
That's a lot of passports I got in the
background.
>> That's a lot of passports I gota
>> London.
>> Right. So you say New Orleans, you do
New Orleans, Houston, LA, Cali. Then
what's the other two cities you feeling
with though?
>> So I actually going to say London, you
know, Houston, Ghana, Denver, and NYC.
>> Denver, that's Colorado. What's up over
there? You got that Denver area.
So, if you had to pick four cities,
where would you go?
>> For me specifically, I definitely love
the LA vibe we had.
>> LA vibe was nice. I ain't going to lie,
the LA vibe was nice.
>> Yeah, LA vibe was nice.
>> That probably our biggest show with like
6:25, 6:30.
>> N got to go home.
>> Got to go home.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> And they don't be showing me no love.
>> That's how I That's how it always is.
I'm biased. And I'm going say like the
DC area.
>> You got You think you You think the DC
area? Yeah. That DMV.
>> Yeah. I think that whole
>> Yeah.
>> So you go you go LA, you go N, you go
DMV. You got to go New York.
>> Yeah. That fourth for myself. Uh
>> I got to go New York. That's my biggest.
>> New York. All right. There it is.
>> So you have one more city. If you did
five cities, where you go at?
>> And then what about Vegas? I don't know
what the price of Vegas
>> I'm not doing nothing. [laughter]
>> I'm not competing with the casinos cuz
>> I'm just saying I saw it. I was like,
"Okay, Vegas might be something. That
might be something."
>> Where the fifth city, LA, N O DMV, NY.
Where do you go?
>> Chicago.
>> M. Chicago over St. Louis.
>> Yeah.
>> You picking Chicago. You picking the
Shai.
>> I ain't mad at the Shy though.
>> Yeah. I got I got a love for Chicago.
>> So, you go Lo, Chicago, DMV, New York.
>> Yep. I'm
>> not mad at it.
>> No Florida,
>> huh?
>> No Florida.
>> No Florida. You ain't got no Florida on
the list.
>> Do you go Miami? Do you go Tampa? Do you
go Jacksonville?
>> Huh? I'm just I don't know.
>> You didn't say Detroit.
>> I didn't.
>> I ain't going to lie.
>> I didn't get the D like that.
>> No, I know Detroit. You know what I'm
saying? I heard there's a lot of check
in you got to do over there before
[laughter] you pull up. You got to make
a couple calls. I don't care if you're
doing financial literacy. You got
>> So we do Detroit for the free.
>> You got to [laughter] call. You don't
come here with them trucks and
>> What about Buffalo?
>> I ain't never been.
>> You went to Buffalo with me?
>> Oh, we did. That's Rob Spot. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. No, Buffalo. Nah,
>> you know Buffalo only got two months of
uh hot weather.
>> Yeah. Same to Chicago.
I think Chicago get three.
>> You c you catch Chicago from May to
July, you good.
>> You catch Chicago from May to July, you
good. Summertime shy. They always say no
nothing like a summertime shy.
>> Hey, that that window short in Chicago.
Anybody from the shop will tell you that
was like you get May, June, July out of
that. It's a done deal.
>> It get nasty cold, too.
>> Yeah, we not doing
>> angry.
>> All right, we'll figure it out, man. All
right, we'll figure it We appreciate
y'all for dropping y'all cities and
states out here in these
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
>> 94% said let's get it.
>> All right. Let's get it, man. Let's get
to the show, man. All right. Got dope
tonight, man.
>> Trap on the charts. Let's get to it.
>> Let's go. You got your pen.
>> I for sure. Stop playing with me. Let me
see it. I said that and remember this
[laughter]
somewhere here. Yeah.
>> Ah, let's get it.
>> Shout out to the the the the crispiness
in that shirt, too.
>> What you mean? The whiteness.
>> The crispiness.
>> But you hit me. You hit it with the
steam. [__]
>> Yeah, I had to steam that jerk.
>> The boy baldled it up. I'm wearing that
right there. It was all baldled up.
>> It wasn't baldled up,
>> [__] It was baldled up, man.
>> It was not baldled up. Ain't nothing in
my house baldled up.
>> It was baldled up on the stage.
>> It was folded.
>> That's why I know you was wearing it. I
say I got to put some compression to
this for real.
>> It was folded, [laughter] Jose.
>> Hey, I'm an iron freak, too.
>> I am, too.
>> Like, I love I can like iron all day.
Real talk. That's my joint.
>> All right, let's get to it, man. All
right, wait up. I'm having an issue with
my internet right now.
Say, bro,
I uh I was reading something the other
day about uh
so you know Love Jones is like one of my
favorite movies, right? [laughter]
Everybody laughing because Yes, we know
cuz you say every episode [laughter]
we need a sponsorship.
>> Something happened with the internet,
Jose, cuz my internet on here not
working either. Huh.
you on um I'mma go to
>> Huh? Which one?
>> Uh how Enterprise jump.
>> I'm on how Enterprise Regular. Switch
it.
>> That's what I'm on.
>> Not 2.4.
>> No,
>> I'm on How Enterprise Regular.
All right, let's try.
>> Somebody said, "Here go to Love Jones."
>> That be my [__] bro. I read something
that uh I was reading. I can't remember
what it was saying. That's what I do in
my in my spare time, bro. Like, you
know, like I'm really on a cool, bro.
Like,
I really like enjoy
um
like romance movies. Mhm.
>> I like them, bro. I think they cool. I
think they dope. I think the
storytelling behind them be good, bro.
And I love what I love most is the
different perspective that you get when
you watch it.
>> Mhm.
>> Right. And so, one of the questions
about Love Jones was that I saw the
thing. It was like it was they said that
the movie was before it time. It didn't
get it didn't get the critical acclaim
like during it. It got the love
afterwards. And I'm trying to ask myself
like what made that movie so like
phenomenal? And then one of the things I
think what made that movie so phenomenal
is because it dealt with the realization
of how two people can actually be.
>> Yep.
>> Because it wasn't the thing about that
movie was it wasn't about the chemistry
at all. It was about the timing.
>> And this is just a this is just a
synopsis of my own. It wasn't about the
chemistry itself. It was about the
timing because it was undeniable that
they had feelings for each other. It was
undeniable that they loved each other,
that they cared about each other, but it
was the timing. He was fresh off a
breakup. She was fresh off a breakup.
And I think the thing that bothered me
the most about that was that there's an
inflection point in that movie. The
inflection point in that movie is when
she go to New York.
>> Yes.
>> And everybody has a different idea what
should have happened in that moment.
men, women, you know, lesbians, you
know, gay men, bisexual, everybody has a
different perspective on what should
have happened in that moment, how he
should have felt, how she he she should
have acted, what she should have done,
what she shouldn't have done. And it
goes to show
>> the reality that love is not always as
simple as people think it is.
>> Say never, [laughter] never.
>> Love is not always as simple as people
make it feel, bro. And I just think and
I'm saying that to say because a lot of
times people be like, you know, I think
Instagram sometimes makes us think that
it's just a fairy tale. But that is a
that is a that is a prototypical and I
look at that I'm like damn that's real.
Like because it's never it's never just
black and white. It's for men it's a
pride thing. You know what I'm saying?
Like you feel like you know I feel I
feel him like I wouldn't I would have
been like cool like that's what you want
to do. That's what you want to do. You
know what I'm saying? But I think in her
mind she was like, "I want to see if he
going to
if he going to tell me no." And in some
strange way a woman want him to be like,
"No, show your feelings. Show me no.
Show me you don't want me to go." But I
guess here he like, "Yo, why would you
even want to go?"
>> Like you see we doing why would you even
want to go?
>> You know what I'm saying? So there's
this there's this thing that says that
love is just such a it's such a unique
thing,
right? And that I don't think we ever
truly figure it out.
>> Yeah. No, no, no. I think that's just my
perspective
>> constant
>> looking at the movie. It's just such a
unique thing that we never figured out,
but yet a lot of us yearn for it.
>> Yeah.
>> You got to think the same thing happened
on Don't Flush Me Martin when Gina was
going to New York and he was like, "All
right, I'll marry you. Dang." You know
what I'm saying? She was like, "That's
the proposal I thought I was going to
get that."
>> He was.
>> So, what is it about it though? What is
it about love that make men prideful?
What is about it that make us prideful?
What is it about it that make us be like
bro like and then for women is like
women to say something like I want a man
who don't play about me. I want a man
who not prideful. But like at what level
do you like hold up your pride?
>> I think most of it is what we saw
growing up.
>> Huh?
>> What we saw growing up. So for us men
for the most part we see how maybe they
treat our our mothers or our uncles had
treated our aunts or things of that
nature. Mhm.
>> Um, that was a big thing for me. I mean,
I saw it in my day like consistent.
>> No, I'm not indirectly talking to
nobody. God damn. I'm just talking about
a movie, man.
>> Look, everybody,
>> there's no hidden there's no hidden
message inside of it.
>> Everybody think it's a reality TV show.
>> Yeah, [laughter] it's not that. I'm not
talking to nobody. I'm just asking a
simple question cuz I even I view movies
sometimes and look at them from
different like even when I look at a
Bronx tail, right? Like why was her
opening the door for him such a pivotal
moment for that movie? And for me as a
man, I use that to this day.
>> Yeah.
>> Like if I get in a car and if I'm in a
car and like if I open the door for you
and the woman doesn't open the door for
me, immediately in my mind, I feel like
you selfish
>> because you saw it in the
>> because I opened the door for you, you
got in the car and start messing with
your makeup or whatever.
>> What about giving you the last uh bite?
>> I don't really care about that.
>> Okay.
>> But it's something about that that gets
me. Like if I open the door for you and
like
>> I walk around the car
>> Yeah.
>> and you don't like extend that, I feel
some kind of way about that.
>> H
>> but again that's a pivotal inflection
point in the movie that it's stuff like
that that I say ah
>> that's damn I see that.
Does it make sense?
>> Yeah. Because I guess also for the most
part you probably that was one of the
main or one of the only representations
that you saw was in the movies. Did you
see it like that in real life at all?
>> Like love, that type of
>> Did you see that in real life?
>> Um, I think as I got older, not as a
kid.
>> Yeah.
>> Like when I get older, and I'll say
this, you know, 100% of the time, like,
you know, like when I met Pocky with
Hood Estates, that was the first time I
saw like, damn, that's a cool ass
marriage. Like I like the way he
indulged with his wife. And there was
times when I looked at Pac, you know,
our relationship ain't no what it was.
Like we don't even talk no more. But
like I remember watching him and his
relationship being like damn. You know
what I'm saying? Like bro really be like
>> Yeah.
>> Like he'll get in a situation like like
his wife like Sandy Sandy from the hood.
They both from the hood. But like Sandy
aggressive. She's an aggressive woman.
You know what I'm saying? She she going
to be like
you know what I'm saying? And and not
saying she's wrong. It's just who she
is. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> But I've seen instances where Paca be
like all right Sandy you got that.
>> But he know like he got control.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. And like him him giving her that
moment didn't take nothing away from
him.
>> Exactly.
>> You know what I'm saying? So I would
watch him do that so many times and I
like damn bro like and I remember one
time I asked him I was like say bro like
you I'm not trying to come at you
sideways and nothing bro like you know
you my bro. Like why how is it so easy
for you to just be like he was like bro
check this out. I've been with that
woman 20 years.
You know what I'm saying? Like I know
her like the back of my hand bro. You
know what I'm saying? And he'll be like,
"In this situation, she just wanted
this. In this situation, she probably
just wanted my attention. In this
situation, da da." So, it takes nothing
for me to be like, "All right, Sandy,
you got that."
>> But I would also watch how she leaned on
him to lead the family. But I would also
watch how when they had a business deal,
he would like bring it to her.
>> Yeah.
>> Like they doing business, he'll be like,
"Sandy, what you think about that?" And
that would make her feel included inside
of the thing. And he would even honor
what she said.
>> Yep.
>> You know what I'm saying? So, and and
there was so there was stuff like that I
took from that. I was like, "Damn."
Like, again, we don't talking, bro.
There's no there's no hate. There's no
nothing. But I watched that and that I
hung around him for two years.
>> Yeah.
>> I was with them for two years. You know
what I'm saying?
>> I think a lot of it too just off the
initial joint was I know we going to get
to the stocks and the trading.
>> Yeah. We got y'all. This was just
conversation y'all. Sometimes you just
want to have a conversation.
>> A lot of times when you so confident in
a thing, it breeds humility.
>> So she could like, "Nah, you got it. I
got you." D we can have a conversation
later. It's not affecting my ego or my
pride because I'm so confident in I know
in our situation in the man that I am
and things of that nature. So it's like
oh yeah it it's a byproduct. Humility is
a byproduct in the moment.
>> I've seen that with my dad like
>> so humility in the man can be a
byproduct of the love that they have.
>> Y love and confidence. I'm so confident
in that thing
>> in our thing. So it doesn't like take
nothing from me like damn she ain't
trying to little boy me cuz never once
like again for me I'm looking I'm like
damn bro she like trying to little boy
my dog
>> but that's me
>> watch this emotionally immature
>> you feel me I'm fresh out the street
when they when I start riding I'm fresh
out the street
>> so I haven't built up that emotion let
like you know what I'm saying but like
you know he done been with her so long
like when she was you know he'll be like
man bro like that just mean she won't do
this or she won't do that. And I'll be
like, "Damn, that was so dope." So, I
admire watching that part of that
relationship, watching him navigate like
her emotion.
>> Yeah, that's
>> You know what I'm saying? Like not
getting like pissed off at her. Like I'm
talking about bro is like let that [__]
like bro let that [__] go off like Walt
like they say like W on a duck.
>> Yeah.
>> Like I would be like bro you are so
phenomenal.
>> Not even saying that I would be pissed
off at but just I had never saw that.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Especially cuz she aggressive woman.
>> You know what I'm saying? Not saying
like she manly or nothing like that, but
she from uh let me get where she from.
Liberty City.
>> So from Miami. She from the trenches.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> She done been through it all. She seen
it all.
>> So you got to Yeah. There's a
>> So she she was aggressive.
>> There's a callous that come with
>> Yeah. So like I would see her,
>> you know, but I would watch how he would
navigate those situations and I watch
how he navigate his family. I watch how
he led his family without always having
to be like the aggressor
or like having to say like
I'm the man of this house.
>> Yeah. That's that's that's weakness.
>> You know what I'm saying? Like never
having to say that.
>> Yeah. That's weak.
>> But always his presence felt.
>> You know what I'm saying? All right,
that's enough of that. I just wanted to
say that.
>> They funny talking about Jose, you
talking different. I said, "Y'all must
never seen my social before. This is
what I do."
>> Don't get him started. Don't get
>> I'm not going to do it. We back to the
track.
>> Don't get hip started. All right. That's
our That's our
>> weekly session before. What time it is?
We got good time.
>> All right. So, let's go. Let's go to
something first and foremost, right? Uh,
can y'all see me?
>> I need to come up with a show though,
dog. I want to do a show where I
interview men, bro, that's married
and like ask them about the different
levels of like marriage, money, and uh
like God or something. You know what I'm
saying? Maybe call it like the gangster
and the gentleman or something like
that. You know what I'm saying?
>> Marriage, money, and ministry.
>> That's what Sean said. [laughter]
Somebody said Wall Street looks like
love now.
>> Whoa. Nah. [laughter] Come on with it.
What Miss Everybody be saying. No, Miss
April don't be saying that. My girl uh
Michelle from Destiny be saying that.
Come on somebody. She [laughter]
always say that. Come on somebody.
>> Huh? We got me up. All right. So we up
right now. Let's get it. So we going to
talk about these charts for a second.
Um,
I'm in my Patreon, bro. And I want to
say something again. I apologize cuz I
did something today. I was so I had so
much going on. I didn't I didn't put
them in this plate. And I I want to
apologize for that. Um, so I want to
stretch this out right to about here.
All right. So,
let me let me go through some. So,
first, let me just say this. Uh, tech
stocks
in general has been getting their ass
beat.
Right. Um, I wanted to show I wanted to
show something today because I know I'm
so transparent with people. Um,
in the be when I came back from July, I
was up two I was up like 2.1 million on
the year. When I came back from July, I
think right now I'm probably up like 1.3
1.4.
Like just like I'm talking about
smacking.
And first it was that million-dollar
play because I lost 300,000 on that. So
that took me down. And then I had uh I
think out of my last 15 plays, I think
probably like eight of them, bro. I went
they just didn't hold up. Like I felt
good with the entries on them. They
probably even popped for a day and then
just fell. You know what I'm saying? And
so just nothing is holding for me right
now. And so I downsized. We did put some
plays in in um we did go healthcare with
some plays. We'll see that tonight. All
my healthcare plays holding up. We
profited on a couple cyber security
plays we took a small profit on, but
it's just not holding up right now. So,
that's kind of the bang I got right now.
Um,
so that's kind of what we got right now.
But I'm always the person to say that
like
you when you run up a big bag, you run
up a big bag and then you just don't
give it all back. You know what I'm
saying? You downsize, you downscale, you
don't force, you start making smaller
trades. So maybe like the last two
weeks, I've been like, "All right,
y'all. Let's just make smaller trades."
You know what I'm saying? If it don't
hold up, we just get out of it. It's all
good. Uh, so here's what happened today.
And and I knew that I knew that I I knew
that they had earnings today. And I also
knew that
all tech earnings. So let me give you an
idea. Let me paint this picture for you
before we get into this. So, here's how
you know that here's how you know that
the appetite for tech has changed
momentarily.
You saw you saw you you've seen there's
has not been one tech company that has
reported earnings that were bad.
They all blew past earnings. Like not
one of them. Micron blew past earnings.
And we talking about pivotal. We gonna
talk about pivotal companies that are
essential to the AI trade. Not just
companies that do what everybody else
do. Like you saw Mike Grime, memory
giant in America until before even
before SK highness came.
Massive earnings. I'm talking about
earnings up 70 81% year-over-year.
Complete breakdown.
TSMC which is needed. 90% of tech stocks
need 90% of semiconductor companies need
this company to make their
semiconductors. Massive earnings showed
that the tech side is like backlogged
and is in full demand. Complete selloff.
ASML makes the machines that the
companies need to make the
semiconductors.
Massive earnings. Complete breakdown.
You know what I'm saying? So that's how
you know right there. Okay. Bet the
appetite is not there for that. For
whatever reason, it's not there. And it
ain't for us to to debate on why is it
there or not. It's for us to sometimes
just sit back and say, "All right, like
leaders have shifted.
When this comes back, we'll be we'll
we'll we'll entertain it, but if it's
not here, we don't want to force it."
So, that was one thing. And then
yesterday, uh yesterday was a key moment
for me.
It was a key moment for me because I
said, "Okay, like again, we we got some
medical plays and honestly they hitting
and we'll I'll show you that." But it
was a key moment for me because when the
market rally on the news that we had,
you know, some idea of the war and then
it just fell off after that, I said,
"Oo,
okay,
okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay. [laughter]
Like I was like, "All right, bet." And
so I think, you know, again, I said like
going into like coming off my birthday
for July, I was probably up like 2.1
million. That's probably why I had the
time of my life. You know what I'm
saying? I'm up 2.1 million on a year.
I'm like, man, we got another 6 months
to go. I'm expecting a little fall in
August, September. I'mma like scale all
the way back. It was like, not so fast,
my friend. I'm about to whoop on you for
30 more days.
Hold on for dear life. You [snorts] hear
me? So probably right now I'm probably
probably at like 1.8 million right now.
So one probably probably like 1.7
million right now. So you figure half a
little more than half a ticket gone. 1.8
9 10 11 12 one. Yep. Probably probably
like 600 gone in a in a matter of 30
days. You know what I'm saying? So I
ain't never lost that. Well, I'm lying.
I'm lying. Before I lie on myself.
Before I lie on myself,
Trump Trump hit me last year. One and a
half, two weeks. [laughter]
[screaming]
[gasps] He put that pressure on me. You
heard me? So, I wanted to show that
though. I had my my thing up. I wanted
to show that just to show people like,
bro, like I'm I'm in the trenches with
y'all. You know what I'm saying? So, but
I'm still proud that I'm up 1.7 at this
point. sitting on a million dollars in
cash right now. So, just wanted to like
tell my people like, you know, I'm here
with y'all, bro. Like, I know I ain't
been here the last couple days, but like
I'm here with y'all. And one thing I
know like my people how we rock is like
damn, it's like new people be like,
"Damn, bro." [clears throat] But my OG's
know like, "Bro, we gonna get all that
back." You know what I'm saying? So, my
OG's know we gonna get all that back.
So, we all right. So, let's talk about
this right quick. So, I want to point
something out right here. And this would
I had kind of had my eye on this. Um,
so we can see right here
this low that I have marked out. Damn.
Wait, let me tap this.
I'll just do it again.
Wait, why my [__] ain't doing that?
All right, there we go. All right, so
that's a low right there, right? We
already know that that's a low. Why is
that a low trap? Because it came off
this high right here,
right? We had this high, which is a
higher high in a trend count. And we
know that higher high has to drop down
at some point to create a what? Higher
low. From that low, we come here, create
a what? Higher high. Drops down here,
creates a what? Higher low. All right.
So, we understand that. So once it broke
past this yesterday and I got off some
plays yesterday because a lot of my tech
plays broke they 50 and once a tech once
a play breaks the 50 for me that mean it
has lost that upward momentum like I'll
rock with a play until it lose the 50
once it lose the 50 you have now gone
against my
rules
like I I'll I'll even be in a draw down
as long as you hold a 50 just being
honest I'll be in a draw down as long as
you holding that 50.
Again, my rules. Everybody not going to
agree with it. This is how I made a lot
of money,
right? I'll be in a draw down. As long
as you holding that 50,
but once you break the 50, I got to let
you go. I got to let you go because now
you've offset my boundaries. You've lost
all short-term momentum. And now you
counting on a 100 day or either the 200
day and I don't want no part of that.
I don't want no part of that. But today
I made an exception to the rule because
I said something before like so I saw
this play. All right. So anyway, now I'm
I'mma say something again here. I gota
you got to be mindful of this. Now
somebody might see it, some people might
not see it. You can go here, here, and
here.
Right. You can go here, here, and here
and say that's a what?
And you wouldn't be wrong. You see it,
Ra. All right. You can go there, there,
and there and says head and shoulder.
You can go shoulder, head, shoulder. And
I would say, you are absolutely right. I
see it.
But today, what I saw was I saw again,
and I said it before, like I missed it
when it did it here. And again, anything
could happen. Right now, it's at 801
overnight. Um, it closed today at
450, 470, something like that. But it
hit this line right here, which was a
So, it bounced on that low right there.
Now, what I did was I took a smaller
position again and I'm adamant about
this. If I'm going to go quarter brick,
I'm gonna go quarter brick. But I put a
leap on it. The reason because it kind
of held that, you know, it kind of
respected that three times. So, I just
want to see I put a leap on it. But now
I know that I do have a I'mma probably
let that one ride unless it drop down
really bad. If it get ugly, then I'll
have no choice. But I was willing to put
a leap on that play
um because it fell down. Now you got to
remember if you look at it from here,
my measuring tube,
it's 34% from the high.
It's 34% from the high.
at that low is 46% from that.
So I made a little play once it like
once I saw it I saw it bounce off that I
put in the leap option play but I didn't
go big on it. I went small probably like
quarter big break cuz y'all know these
is expensive. So just wanted to respect
that. Um and so yeah, no that's not a
double top.
It's not a double top. Um so that was a
play I got in y'all and y'all see that
tonight. But let's look at something
right quick. Let's look at something.
All right. So, let's look at the Q's
right now. We'll talk about that for a
second. So, right now, your Q's again,
the downtrend is in. You see the
downtrend. Um, but I do want to show
y'all something right now. The Q's as of
right now today, it did touch bare, not
bare, it did touch correction territory.
I don't know why my chart tripping.
It closed at right at it 9.77%.
So you can call that correction
territory for sure. So right now
technology that's why I said it ain't
just memory, it's just technology in a
whole as a whole has entered correction
territory. So be mindful of that because
that's at 667.
But know that your 200 day is at 643. So
that is not far right now. I will say
this. If the Q's hit the 200 day, I
would put another leap on the Q's. I'm
just being real. I will put a leap on
the cues for one year simply because I
want to see if institutions going to
respect that 200 day. Normally they do
unless they get real scared and I would
have to honor that. But notice if it
comes down to that, you're talking about
a 13% drawback. Now notice that that
doesn't happen in one day.
It can it can get the rest of that in
one day because that ain't nothing but
another 4%.
But that's that's typically a a one
week, week and a half, two week, you
know. So I'm going say this like be
mindful of
small rallies
because that can really just be a lower
high setting. And so in this scenario,
here's what we know what happens. Stocks
will rally to get what? Buyers in and
then sell off to what? Trap buyers
and that you become liquidity.
So they'll push the market up just to
take your money because you think the
rally over and then they'll fall back
down and now you become a trap buyer. So
um let's just be mindful of that. Now
here's how we know the whole market
isn't in that phase.
Is am I making sense everybody right
now?
All right. So, let's go to the spy. Now,
here's how we know the spy isn't
suffering the same thing. And I'm going
to show y'all one more. Look at the
difference on the spy. And so, this
tells us that leaders are somewhere
else. Why do we know that? Because the
spy is only down
2%.
2 and a half% from the high. It did give
up to 20. It did give up to 50, but it's
only down two and a half% from the high.
So that mean the issue is all in the end
technology, right? And here's another
way for us to look at it.
This is the eco weighted index,
the one I talked to about a a couple
weeks ago. It's hitting all-time highs.
So this shows you that the rally is the
the it's only in technology. So you can
look at that one or two days. So this
the equal weighted index and then the
equal weighted index that's everything
weighs the same. So no one is the sole
carrier of this. So everything weighs
the same up in here. This is important
because this shows us that there is not
a total market correction. It is just in
technology.
It is just in technology.
So I just wanted to put that out there
so we can see that. So, we can pay
attention to that. Um, so we don't get
caught up in, man, the market is selling
off. No, no, no. It's just in
technology. And let's go a little
further.
We'll look at a couple things,
right? We'll look at the semis. Here we
go. Here.
Notice we had a small gap here,
right? So, you had a gap filled there um
to the downside. Let's see how far the
Sims is down.
Semiconductors are down 21% which puts
the semis in a bare market.
So your semiconductors are having bare
market territory. They're in bare market
territory at 21%.
Right? So now let's look and then we
look at semimes.
You know, you can say it. You can you
can do this if you want and and I'm not
mad at it. You can say I see this trap.
I see this trap and I see this. I'm not
mad at it. Or you can say I see this.
Right. Shoulder, head, shoulder.
All right. So not mad at that. And
Here
is your
software which is still really not doing
anything. Just messing people up. You
know what I'm saying? So just be mindful
of what you have here, right? So I would
say if you if you're a tech trader,
you're somebody that's looking at tech
like I am, just be mindful. There's
other leaders elsewhere and we can look
at those leaders
XLV which is healthcare running alltime
high got a gap fill here
know that's pretty good XLV running so
that's good so it's not the whole market
you got to be mindful of that We can go
XLI. Let's see if we got anything here.
Not too bad. Holding a 20. That ain't
bad. Bounce off the 20. I like it.
That's the industrials. Remember we said
Hellcat Financials Industrials is what's
been running the market.
Let's see what XLF doing.
New highs here. XLF, same thing, right?
New alltime highs.
Um, and let's go XLR
real estate.
Yeah. So, again, alltime highs. Came off
it a little bit today, but you can see
your step right here.
If you want to do it, you can bring it
here. That go your trend right there.
Boom.
You feel me? So you see a trend, it's
sitting there for you. So again, real
estate, healthc care, financials, and
industrials, that's kind of what's
leading the market. Tech is not leading
the market right now. Even though you
have companies like Apple jumping up. So
you somebody that loves tech like
myself, you got to be mindful that you
going to have to pivot somewhere right
now or go smaller in positions. But
don't force a trade, y'all. Do not force
a trade that's not there. Also, you
don't have to be the person trying to
catch it at the bottom.
You don't, oh, I got it at the bottom.
Don't be that person because I promise
you that bottom can be a abyss.
You chasing that bottom could turn into
the abyss.
You know what I'm saying? So, don't now.
If you trying to be somebody that's
looking for buy and hold, this can be
perfect situation for you to buy in,
right? this could be perfect situation
for you to buy in. But that would be my
um
recommendation. Like don't try to chase
the bottom, y'all. You know what I'm
saying? Don't try to chase the bottom.
All right, let's get into it, man. My
oranges came. That's good. It's April.
It's April. That's my oranges.
Could you cut them? Could you get one of
them and cut it in four for me, please?
Thank you.
Let's go, man.
Let's see the money, man.
Trap smarter than Yeah. Don't be chasing
the bottles, man.
Don't be Don't Don't Don't be chasing
the bottoms, man. All right. So, as you
can see, man, we are like we are we are
and let me show you like I got some
green on the table, but I promise you
like
I I I cut like six plays, y'all. So,
yeah. So, and again, my winners are
healthc care plays and uh Consumer is is
winning, too. So, AV was a play we put
in. I know the Patreon kind of panicked
on that a little bit. Um but that one
exploded for us. Um, CR YX was a play we
have and then it's a small position for
me, but it's all right. Goldman Sachs
the last two days gave up for me. So, I
was positive on that. Not big, but
positive on it. Gave up for me. Um,
there's my Eli Liy trade. It's I'm not
going to lie, like Lily is probably my
biggest position right now. I got a bag
up in that. Like, I entered that play
with a bag. Like, I pointed out that um,
so we looked at Lily. Matter of fact,
can we go Can we go back to the uh, can
I go back to my chart right quick?
um
just to show my people like we really be
charting but again like you know we look
I look for certain things I see certain
things and then again some of the trades
has just been bottoming out on us so
they haven't been holding form and I'm
okay with that
all All right.
So, I think last week I talked to y'all
about um I talked to y'all about this.
Remember I told y'all about Let me open
it up.
But it done exploded out of it. But
remember, I told y'all about this
and then I talked to y'all about this
was here. And I said that uh once it
broke outside of that, we would see some
movement on that. Is my screen up? Yep.
And so far we it done popped out of that
sucker. Uh and it looked pretty good,
right? Popped out of that. We got in it,
right? We got in it. We got in actually
we was a little anticipatory because I
saw it forming. So we got in it a little
bit early. We might have got in it I
want to say we got in this play probably
about right here
cuz I saw it forming.
Um and I said that flag is forming right
there y'all. Um I said but if it can
break outside of this box it break
outside of that flag we gonna go. And so
we kind of have went um definitely want
to see it jump over all-time highs. Um
and I think we can go I think if it can
jump over alltime highs now we talking
about
we talking about um
price discovery. So that would be real
cool um on that. And then the other one
was the same thing.
Um it did it twice. So there we go right
here. Did it again. But then on this
one, we had the I pointed this out to
the squad.
We had the rectangle.
So you had the pole and then a
rectangle. And but I think we had it
here though. I think I had it right
here. Yeah, I had it right here. And I
said, "Yo, if it break that, if it
breaks that, we going to go." Um, so we
didn't we up now. So we done now claimed
new territory here. And so we kind of
cool with that. Um, again, want to see
that keep running. But we see we got out
of that flag, then it created another,
um, flag but with the rectangle on it.
So,
uh, just wanted to show that out. So,
once you start seeing bull flags start
to form up like that, those will be
typical and strong stocks right now. So,
bull flags and you'll start seeing bare
flags and and ones that's breaking down.
So, I just wanted to show that to the
squad right quick.
Just wanted to show that on my butt.
There we go. Just wanted to show that to
the squad right quick and I hope that
that helped uh some people out.
Um so yeah. Uh so we got Eli Lily
uh popped for 35 grand a day. We got
Monster. Now I know my Patreon I know we
kind of panicked on Monster because we
was here before with Monster. We was up
on Monster for two days. We got in the
play perfect. It ran up for three days
and then it gave up everything.
But the crazy part of why it was it gave
up everything but it didn't drop hard.
It just gave up everything and it just
got tight. You know what I'm saying? But
because it's a stock that don't move. So
if it move a dollar, it's a lot. You
know what I'm saying? So it was moving
like a dollar here, dollar. So it was
down on it. Um I was actually in this
one play. I was down 15 grand, but at at
a point I was up like four grand, right?
So it fell out. I was like, damn, the
bottom went out on here. But I was like,
bro, like it. But again, like I said, it
held it 50.
It held a 50. So that was looking good.
Merc, we've been in Merc for a minute. I
think we up like 66%. You know the thing
that always make you mad about some
plays, and I think everybody gonna have
this issue. It's like plays that be up
like 60 and 70%. You be like, "Bro, why
I don't have more in there?" You know
what I'm saying? When you get them ones
that break that 50, they be like, "Oh,
I'm up 50%, 60%, 70%, 80%." Bro, why I
only got 40, 50 grand in there, 60 grand
in there. And I know people like,
"Nigga, that's a lot." No, I'm used to
dumping 200 and something, 150, 200. So,
but I had But again, that's me
understanding where I was at in my
portfolio, like looking at how much
money I got sitting on the side, how
many plays I made. All right, scale
down, bro. You know what I'm saying? So,
I think that's one of the things a lot
of people need to learn, too, though, is
like as you start, there's a point where
you got to start sizing down, and we
call that progressive exposure. though.
Anyway, um Morgan Stanley play is down a
bit. Let's go a little further. Um that
go to Morgan Stanley play. That's the
STX play I had put in. And then our
energy play is down. So that's what I
got right now, y'all. Not in a lot. Um
again, sitting on a million in cash on
the side. And honestly, I'm not in a
rush to deploy it [laughter]
unless I can find me some good
consumers,
um, some consumer plays, some medical
plays, some real estate plays, or some
because that's just a cycle win right
now. And I'm not going to force it. I'm
I know people like Tra, why you don't go
play puts? I'm not about Yeah, I could
have made a fortune if I was playing
puts. That's just not my game. You know
what I'm saying? I've made 90% of my
money, 95% of my money, not necessarily
in bull markets, but finding great
sectors that's running even if the
market going down. And that's just my
game plan, bro. Like, I don't got to I'm
going to stick to what work. I'mma stick
to what got me here. And knowing that,
I'm just open enough to say that
sometimes you just go through the, you
know, some choppy waters. And just being
able to navigate that is cool. You know
what I'm saying? I'm okay with that,
bro. Like, I'm perfectly fine with that.
And if somebody like I always use this
reference. If somebody like Bill Atman
can lose 460 million on a trade, man, I
ain't tripping. You know what I'm
saying? So anyway, let's go a little
further.
Let's show them the buying hole.
Sean buying ho is getting punched in the
face cuz bro and it's because so MU is
still up but it was up you know I was up
150 in that sucker. Um my PWR done went
negative.
>> Costco don't went negative.
EME done went negative. Nvidia don't
went negative. This is whooping me. So
anyway, I was up 40% on this sucker. Now
we up 19%.
Got a hot 30,000 sitting on the side.
So, we still beating the market though.
So, that's
>> I was just about to ask you where the
market at.
>> We still beating the market. So, I ain't
mad at that. Uh, the market is up. The
S&P is up. Uh, let me put it up.
>> It's not up a lot.
>> Mark is up 8% year to date.
>> Yeah,
>> Mark is up 8%. That's the oranges. Thank
you, man. That's my snack.
It's
>> my snack.
>> Huh?
>> Who is that?
>> You know that's her nickname, Miss Amy.
>> Where'd that come from? I'm not calling
you that.
>> I'm not calling you that.
>> If you're nasty.
>> Who?
[laughter]
>> Excuse me, ma'am.
>> You got a little feisty since she moved
out here. I just want you to know.
All right, let's get to it. Jose,
>> man, Jose slipping, y'all. Jose slipping
again. Jose slipping. No boo.
[music]
Wall Street.
>> So Patreon,
we still locked in. We still get busy.
My girl Jamaican Spice in the building.
Yes, that is Miss Abram talking about
something. Call her Amy. I lost her
mind. All right, let's get to it.
So,
325 stocks in the S&P 500 are higher
today. Second day in a row. The S&P
advanced decline line is one good day
away from a new high. Now,
the reason why I'm showing this because
I want you to understand that I don't
want you to get
um
I don't want you to get so caught up in
what you seeing on TV to where you
forget that the market is still strong.
The market's still strong.
It's just technology, specifically semis
and semi associated companies
are getting beat up.
But you also got to remember
even though they getting beat up,
a lot of them still up double and triple
digit.
So
the idea isn't that they crashing, it's
just that we seeing some we seeing a lot
of people taking their money. They like,
"Bro, we just think about it. SNDK was
up 900%, y'all,
from January to June.
Bro, even if it crash another 200%.
It's still up 600%.
Still up 600%.
Even if it ended even if it ended the
year up 200%.
It's a phenomenal year.
It takes some stocks five years to get
100%.
Make sense?
So,
I don't want y'all to just take this for
granted and be like, "Oh, man. The
market crash and the market crashing.
The market crash and the market
crashing." Don't look at it like that.
Don't look at it like that.
You know, technology, think about that,
bro. Like, it's still still going crazy.
So, like, don't don't lose track of
that.
All right. So, let's go a little
further.
Somebody say Bloom Energy is down 20%.
Bloom Energy is up 109% year to date.
What you talking about?
It's up 109% year to date. It's up 443%
in one year. It's up 786% in one. You
know what I'm saying? And after hours
it's up about 13%.
You just got to be willing to, you know
what I'm saying? like look at the bigger
picture and again I'll be honest with
you
in a Patreon we made a lot of money
made a lot of money
the problem becomes
when you keep trying to chase it and you
keep throwing more money at it like big
lump sums of money trying to get that
back like me when I lost it. When I lost
a 300,000 on a million dollar trade, I
didn't go put another million in it
trying to get it back. I was like, "All
right, bet. You got me."
The play I put in today wasn't even much
a big play.
Like, all right, bro. Like, you stuck me
for that. I'mma get mine back. May not
be today. Mine might be tomorrow. It
might don't be till October.
Come and get that back. All of it.
But if you lose all your money now,
you don't got no money to fight.
Remember, your money is your your money
is your war. Your money is your
ammunition.
Your money is your ammunition.
And you run out of ammunition, you can't
you can't fight the war.
If you run out of ammunition, you can't
fight the war. So, if you see, all
right, yo, the market is kind of not
going in my favor. My setup's falling
through. Like I was talking to one of my
people, I said, a couple of my people
that's not even in the Patreon. They got
their other things going. I was like,
man, you know, how you navigating right
now? They were like, man, you know, just
taking smaller position sizes, got some
healthc care, got some like [__] that's
what we doing, too. Like, oh [__] Like,
I ain't tripping. And that's kind of my
I'm not going to lie, it's kind of like
my energy. Like, all right, we sitting
on a million on the side. And I'm not
saying that everybody has that luxury,
but my million could be your 10,000.
My million could be your 5,000. My
million could be your 100,000. I don't
know. I don't count people pocket. What
I'm saying is I know we ran it up so
much. If you gave it all back in two
months or six weeks, it's because you
started playing, you started gambling,
you started revenging, you started
disregarding what's going on. All right.
The setup's not holding up. No. Once one
setup don't hold up, cool. Once two sets
don't hold up, all right, none of these
setups holding up. All right, I need to
do one or two things. I'mma sit on the
side or I'mma decrease. And once I
decrease, move my stop up. Stop. Pop.
I'm out of there. Pop out of there. So
now you ain't waiting for 30% no more.
Hey, bro. That's that sucker fall 15%.
I'm good on it. You know what I'm
saying? Unless you say, "All right, I'm
gonna go leap option." And then now even
if if you saying, "All right, but watch
this. You're not going leap just to
You're not going leap just because you
about to make a bad trade. You going
leap because you saying, "Hey, based on
what I see, based on the mechanics
that's going on, I'm willing to push
this off for 12 months, but because of
this environment, I'm not about to rock
the house on this. I'mma go even smaller
cuz a leap going to cost you a little
bit more." Right? So, you got to
understand the dynamics of the game
right here. Right? So don't you know and
and it's hard because you get on
Instagram and the sky is falling.
Don't fall for that. All right. Average
return before midterm election 0%. US
equities have typically traded sideways
ahead of the midterm elections. So
midterms is in what? November.
So this is the average return since
1984. You know, it just goes sideways,
sideways, sideways, and then just on
average after that, you get the upside.
You know what I'm saying? So not saying
it's going to bang out to November. Just
saying like be careful here.
That's all. Like even in the lead, it's
like I'm not about to go chase Apple
right now. Right. When everybody started
falling, boom, they shot out the gate. I
was like, "Oh, look at Apple. Never got
a real good pullback on them. I'm not
about to chase it.
I'm not about to chase it.
Trap diversify and getting your day
trading back. You control risk better.
So, here's the thing that I don't never
want to do. I'm not a day trader.
So, because I'm not a day trader, I'm
not about to pivot to day trading just
to try to make some money right now. No,
I'm not going to do that. You know what
I'm going to do? Tell You know what I'm
going to tell all my day traders? Keep
getting that bag, bro. Keep getting that
bag, sis.
That's people always try to do that.
Like people like, "Oh man, you should."
No, I should do what been working for
me. Day trading ain't made me a couple
million dollars.
Day trading ain't get me out of that $
1.5 million hole. Know what got me out
that $ 1.5 million hole? Swing trade.
Following my rules. Know what made me $4
million in one year? Swing trade. Leap
trade.
know what got me up $2 million by my
birthday. Swing trading. Why would I
switch to day trading?
Nothing against day traders.
That's like a boxer saying, "Yo, I'm
about to go I'm about to go do some UFC,
bro. You about to get slaughtered cuz
you good with the hands." But the minute
somebody kick you and put you on the
ground, you're dead.
They going to ground and pound you, bro.
And before you know it, rear necked
choke. Easiest choke in the game. Ain't
even hard. Just this. We've been doing
this. We've been rear neck choking
people since we was kids, right? He be
like, "Damn, how I get caught in that?
Cuz you a boxer." Stay your stupid ass
in the ring. I'm sorry. Stay in the
ring. Stay where you got the advantage
at.
Go to day trade. Come back next week and
be like, "Hey, I lost it all."
Hit the bomb. We got 3,000 in the chat.
Shout out to y'all.
Got everybody want day trading can get
daily income. I don't need daily income.
Day trading also can become daily
losses,
right? Let's talk about talk about both
sides of it.
Day trading can also create daily losses
because I got to lose before I learn.
I'm not just gonna step into day trade
going crazy. You know how long it took
me to get where I'm at right now?
What have been the loss I had to endure
to get here?
You think two months about to make me
switch my whole playbook
just cuz I won't make
daily income.
I'm straight.
I know who I am. Proud of who I am.
I am I'm with you.
I'm not letting other people influence
me, bro.
That's why I say like even my my my dog
Cal
Kev.
Cal be hitting
and then I be showing the [__] I be
doing.
He be like, "I ain't lie. I got to give
it to you, dog."
Like a lot of times like we'll text each
other. He'd be like, "Bro, you on this?"
I'll be like, "Yep." He be like, "You on
this?" I be like, "Yep." I show him. He
like,
"I see you, boy." You know what I'm
saying? Hit for 100, 200, 300, 400. He
like, "Damn, boy." That's But you know
what I do with him? You killing it, dog.
When he popping this stuff, pop it.
Nothing about what he do make me want to
go be a Strat trader.
But guess what I do? respect him in his
strap.
I respect it. I salute to him and I can
keep going.
You know what I'm saying? Like, you got
to be cool with that. It's taking away
from day traders, though. Anyway, let's
go. So, the top 10 stocks control nearly
40% of the S&P 500. Watch this. In 1990,
it was Exon Mobile. Um,
[laughter]
I see you Pascal for sure. Um,
so it said like in 1990 it was 25%.
Watch this. It was Exxon Mobile, General
Electric, IBM, AT&T, Sigma, Ultra, Merc,
PNG,
um, Bristol Meers. Then in 2000 the top
10 made up 30%.
General Electric, Cisco, this the do
bubble. J Electric, Cisco, Microsoft,
Amazon, Intel, Walmart, Oracle, IBM,
City Group, AIG. It's crazy that AIG,
which is an insurance company, was in
the top 10 during
the um.com
bubble. Then 2005, it shifted to General
Electric. They dropped down to a little
than 25%. You talk about AIG, Exon
Mobile. Exon Mobile been hanging in
there for a long time. Think about this.
In 2010, Exon Mobile was the number one
company, the biggest company in the S&P
500. Think about that for a second.
They lost in 1990. They had the spot.
They came back and got their spot in
2010. But watch this. 95 2000. So for 10
years, General Electric ran the market.
That's crazy. Now watch the pivot. 2015,
Apple took over.
Now Apple just took over again,
right? So the top 10 stocks and it's the
greatest of all time. No, no, no. Never
has the top 10 stocks in the market had
this much market cap. Um, and that's
So now nice Apple, Nvidia, Google,
um Microsoft, Amazon,
uh Broadcom, Tesla, Meta, Micron, and
Eli Liy. I actually think I'm about to
say something that's going to be
um
I'm about to say something that's gonna
be real.
I don't know where I'm going use here.
I think Tesla gonna fall out the top 10.
I think everybody else can hold up.
I think Tesla gonna fall out the top 10
because there's other companies coming
and
they not selling like that no more.
Too much competition.
They going to have to merge SpaceX and
Tesla.
It's the only way.
I think they gonna fall out the top 10.
I think the the the the I think that
people tired of them not coming through.
I think investors are tired of them not
coming through. 100%. Let's go a little
further.
All right. From 2008 on, here's the Mag
7 midyear
or midterm performance so far. Apple has
been the best performer during all
midterm years so far. This is me just
giving y'all data data data data data
data data,
right? Um, Apple has been the best
performer so far in these midterm uh
years. Nvidia is coming in second. Um,
likes to make up a lot of its gains in
the second half of the year. typically
choppy during the first half and that
has been the that has been the call for
Nvidia so far too. It's like the second
half of the year they ex they they like
go up the first half of year they just
be yeah um Microsoft has been a steady
grinder um Amazon has been in fourth
place Alphabet has been in fifth place.
Meta and Tesla has came in last place
during midterm year elections. Now, this
is from 2008.
Um, and it's from December, July to
December. So, it's just one half of the
year.
So, it's just one half of the year. So,
not saying this all throughout the whole
year, just saying one half of the year.
Typically, from July to December, this
how the Mag 7 has held up during that
time. Let's go a little further.
Stephen on fire with these.
So the tech recovery technology is down
12% from its peak right
56 days in counting. The median sell-off
drops 25%.
And bottoms in around 73 days. This is
only one. This one is only 12% deep in
56 days. And it's one of the shallowest
on record. Every single technology draw
down in history has recovered to a new
all-time high. Everyone, if this follows
the same mat, we're looking at a late
bottom forming in around late August or
September. Let's go a little further.
Now, my reason for saying that was so
you can see this. How long text
recovered? This has been since 1998.
Um, sleeping on Tesla human or robot
still the bestselling car in the world?
It's not.
Tesla is not the bestselling car in the
world. BYD blew Tesla out the water the
last last the last two the last two
um the last two earnings BYD the Chinese
they blew Tesla out the water. I'm
talking about like blew them out the
water. So, they not the bestselling car
in the world. And that's just based on
um that's based on data. Um not sleeping
on a Tesla humanoid robots, but again,
you're going now into a industry that
you're not the only one.
You know how many people, you know, how
many other people making humanoids? They
got them out right now. So, yeah, I
don't agree with you on that. I agree
with you on that. All right. So, I'mma
just go through some of these. Um the
draw down for tech. Um
um the 2006 rotations at 12% from the
high. The 2025 tariff crash that lasted
49 days. Days to all-time high 75 days.
Did it recover? Yes. Um late 25 dip.
Late 2025 dip in November. It lasted 39
days. Days to all-time high 108 days.
Did it recover? Yes. 2024 summer
rotation. I felt that one. I remember
that one. That was a headbanger.
Um 2024 rotation lasted 26 days. Number
of days to alltime high 80. Did it
recover? Yes. 2022 bare market. That's
when we started this show. That's when
all my trades was in Netflix and in oil.
Netflix oil and Ultra Beauty. That's
when we started the show. That's when I
say, "Oh, I'm on buy it now.
um
lasted 22 days, 282 days.
Um 361 days. Did it recover? Yes. Um co
COVID crash. Um draw down days in the
bottom 33 days. Um took 74 days to get
to alltime high. Um 2018 sell off. I
remember that was by George. Remember I
remember talking to George about that
over Thanksgiving.
Um, look at that. It says bottomed in
December. I remember that. 82 days, 119
days till it came to alltime high. Did
it recover? Yes. The debt ceiling, I I
don't remember this, but that's the
data. Um, 18%.
Bottom 74 days. Um, took 58 days to get
back to all-time high. Financial crisis
was the longest one. Um, no, it wasn't.
The dot burst. The financial crisis was
2008. Um 51% lasted 495 days. Took 1,200
days to get back. So that's about what 3
years to all-time high. Four years to
get to all-time high. Um and the do
bubble October 2002 lasted 926 days.
Took 4,256
days to get back to all-time high. So
being had being able to endure
4,000 days is about six years about
eight years
longer. So you got 365. Matter of fact,
365 times 10. So that mean it took 10
years. 10 11 years. She took about 11
years to get back to alltime high. He
figured 365 time 10 and he said it took
what? 4,000. So yeah, it took about 11
and a half years to get back to alltime
high.
About 11 and a half years. So from 2000
what that was 2002.
I mean it took the 2012.
I hope we of that
[__]
Rob. I hope we that
man. Audible, man.
I ain't going to lie, though.
I'm about to say something that's really
crazy.
We overdo for one of them.
H
>> like we overdo and I'm I'm saying this
not to like you know be pessimistic or
nothing like that.
We overdo for one of them
one year twoyear bare markets that last
for a long time. [laughter]
We over one of them cuz now don't get me
wrong 2022 it lasted for a whole year.
So I guess though I guess in 2022, we
had one in 2022.
You know what I'm saying? It lasted for
a whole year. So I ain't So I guess so.
I guess so. I guess we can go with that.
2022, 282 days. That was the whole 2022.
And it took 361 days to get us back.
Damn. [snorts]
I think we overdo for one of them ones
that last about two years though. God,
last one was in 2008.
2022 they are getting shorter and
shorter and you know why they getting
shorter and shorter.
Well, not really cuz 2022 300 Yeah.
Well, 2022 was
one year,
then everything 26, 39, 46, 56. Yeah.
>> Long
>> because I think because I think we
overdue for a recession.
Yeah, that I agree with. Yeah,
>> we done printed a lot of money in the
system, dog.
>> That pandemic money got to come out of
here.
>> What type of recession do you feel like
we need to have based on how much money
cuz we put a lot. We didn't really have
no recession in 2020.
>> That's what I'm saying. I think we I'm
not saying that I want to happen.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm not saying it's going to happen.
I'm saying we overdue for one of them
moments where
>> it just reset.
>> Huh?
>> Like it just reset
>> like a big re. So we would have had that
reset in the pandemic. That's why they
put all that money in the market
>> to bail us out. Yeah.
>> That's why they put all that money in
the market. They put all that money,
man. Lieutenant Casey right there. I
remember we was talking about this
during that time 2021, 2022. We was
talking about how like we don't want
like we don't know what it's like for
America not to be the big dog.
You know what I'm saying?
Putting four trillion,$6 trillion
dollars in the market doesn't help us.
>> Yeah.
>> That's why the debt n is out of control
cuz once you That's the thing. Once you
do it once,
it's easy to do it from here on out.
>> Yeah.
>> You know what I'm saying? So like if we
didn't put that money in the market,
the pandemic essentially was supposed to
send us into a recession.
But
we ain't get that.
>> It was supposed to send us into a
recession. Why? Because people not
working.
People not working, people not spending
money. People not spending money,
businesses get shut down. Businesses get
shut down, people start losing their
houses. People start losing this. And
I'm not saying I want that to happen at
all. What I'm saying is once you put
four trill 6 trillion dollars in the
market into the economy,
that money has to come out.
>> Well, why can't they just keep printing
money? Cuz that's what you said. They've
been doing that
>> the past six years they've been doing
that. They they have been keep putting
more money, more money, more money.
>> You saying why they can't keep printing
money?
>> Yeah. Why can't they keep doing it?
>> Cuz we going to keep going in debt. So
now we at $39 trillion in debt.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, it's costing us a billion dollars
a day to sue or service that debt.
That's because two $2.1 billion a day to
service that debt. Well, what's
happening now is we not making that much
money.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's where the GDP comes at debt to
GDP. So what happens is the GDP is
saying, okay, this is how much money,
you know, America bring in,
right? Well, what's happening is
>> we got way more debt than money we
earning. And what happens next next to
that is
now we gota we got to now take on more
debt to service the loan
because the loan is us paying people who
are buying treasury bills. So that's why
when I heard I heard um
what's his name? Um Kevin Olirri he said
you're not rich until you got $5 million
in tea bills. Well here's why. Because
tea bills are money that's backed by the
government that they got to pay you. So
if you got $5 million in tea bills, that
mean you got you liquid cuz they paying
you that money
>> month after month after month after
month after month. So you become part of
the debt payment that the America got to
pay.
>> You feel me?
>> Yeah. So, the problem with that is,
so let me say this, and I'm gonna say
this in a way that uh
>> that probably ain't the best way to
saying it, but
the re one of the reasons why I think
that Trump took Venezuela,
>> I thought the gate was
>> was to get that oil,
right? It was untapped. There was it's a
whole bunch of oil over there, but it's
going to take years for them to get it
the way they want. That's why he said,
"I'mma put my oil companies over there."
Chevron, Exxon, uh, Valero, all of them,
right? To to to to turn that into usable
crude oil. What happens is if you take
that and it it belongs to America now,
you can use that
to help start paying the debt down
because oil gets sold in what? The
American dollar. So now you got to
convert your money to American money and
that American money can then start
paying down the oil. So now you use a
portion of that to pay down the debt.
Now I'm not saying that that was the
right thing to do. I'm not saying none
of that. What I am saying is
I think I just dug myself in a hole
right here. All right. What I am saying
is that this
we live in a world where man
man
All right, let me say this the right
way. I don't agree with this,
but they don't run the world under godly
principles.
They run the world off rules of power
and power and in they rule book God and
power don't go together.
Does that make sense? Like in our rule
book the way we like no God and money.
So mean God first and then everything
comes after that because that gives us
moral compass on how to do certain
things. It's not saying you get it all
right, but it's saying like I ain't
going I ain't willing to do that cuz
that interferes with the the the God
principles that I live by, right? And
I'm not saying that nobody I don't I'm
not questioning nobody belief system.
But when you run in and the world is all
about conquering,
you know, people want their country to
be the number one country. People that's
why we have armies. That's why we do
certain things. It's all about power.
And so when you feel like your country
is in a default or facing some type of
um
threat of default or being conquered,
you look for somewhere to go hit so that
could give you a some leverage. And so
they saw that up this leverage right
here. Let's go get that. You know what
I'm saying? Same reason you bomb Saddam
Hussein. Same reason you killed Gaddafi.
like you want to try to get leverage.
You know what I'm saying? It's not
justifiable. It's not right. But that's
the game they playing. So yeah, let me
let me get out of that before it gets
sticky. Let's go a little further.
All right. So the retail risk appetite
has surged. So the retail risk appetite
among retail investors is through the
roof. Think about this. 55% of call
options on US big tech stocks is now in
play. Of all new options positions open
by retail investors on a 20-day average
basis, 55% of them have been called
options on tech.
You know why?
You know what they saying?
I'm about to buy the dip and go long.
That's what's being h that's what's
happening right now. People like, "Oh,
this how they thinking. I know how they
thinking,
man. It's down 30 something%. I'm about
to I'm about to go. It's got to turn
around." Not realizing like that crap
could turn into the abyss.
That crap go down another 30 40% cuz on
an individual stock basis.
You got to remember, bro, like SNDK fell
14% in one day, bro.
14% in one day.
I just wanted to be mindful of that,
right? This metric newly initiated call
option positions rather than total
trading volume highlights the current um
direction um bets of retail investors.
This figure has surged 10% t 10
percentage points since the late March
market bottom. By comprom by comparison,
the peak during the 2020 pandemic was 57
55%. And this um metric bottomed at 35%
during the 22 bare market. Retail
investors are positioned for more upside
in tech. And I'm just telling you what
it is. Now, here's my thing. I want us
to get money.
I want us to run that bag up. And the
reason why I wanted to run that bag up,
bro, is because I feel like we are the
generation that can set the tone. Like,
we the generation that got to go through
it. You feel what I'm saying? We we the
ones, y'all. We the ones. And I'm saying
we the one cuz like I'm born in the 80s.
So, like, it's my generation and the
generations behind me. So, it's me if
you born in the 80s, the And I'm not
just picking on myself. Here's why.
Because the people born in the 70s, they
had a different set of rules. And the
reason why they had a different set of
rules because they had different things
going on,
right? So think about it. Here's here's
my thing. In the 60s, 50s, they was
fighting for humanity.
60s and 70s, they was fighting for civil
rights. By the time the 80s come, we
were stepping into hip-hop,
right? We were stepping into like, all
right, well, we bolder. We felt bolder.
Like, you know, we felt a little bolder.
We felt a little like, nah, bro. like,
"Man, we ain't going." You know, me and
a friend of mine, we got a saying like,
"Man, we ain't going." You know what I'm
saying? It's like, "We ain't going." So,
like, that 80s generation, I think, and
I'm not saying that my generation was
better than no generation. I'm not
saying that. I'm saying every generation
had a different fight. And I think by
time the 80s generation came, we was on
some like, "Bro, we ain't going."
Straight up, we ain't going. Now,
whether we would have went or not, I
don't know. But we had the attitude
like, "We ain't going." Think about we
had Public Enemy, we had MC Light, we
had Queen Latifah. You know what I'm
saying? Now, I will say this. We didn't
have the leadership that the other
generations had, but we had the music
public enemy. You feel me? So, we had
the individual leadership. We didn't
have the Malcolm. We didn't have the
Martin. We didn't have the Fred. We
didn't have that. But we didn't even
have the uh HR Brown. We didn't We
didn't have it, right? But we had the
music. And the music told us, "Fight the
power.
Fight the power. Fight the power. You
got to fight the power of that. Run it
for your life. For your life. Running."
We had the music. So the music kind of
gave us like, "Yeah, all right. We
there." So again, by the time the 90s
came, we was like, "All right, bet."
Like, think about this though. Like even
NWA, it was gangster rap, but it wasn't
really gangster rap as far as Kill My
Dog. It was, "Hey bro, them police
tripping. I'm seeing murder, but my my
beers is really with them police."
Ice Cube, I mean Ice Tea, bro got public
in number one from Ronald Reagan. He got
banned.
Cop killer. They banned the song.
I te Cop killer. They banned the song.
Like bro was like public number one for
that.
>> And now he play a cop in every TV show.
And
>> let me stay out [laughter] of that. But
then the music transitioned because they
realized this too powerful.
This too powerful. Like it's hard for us
to like and I'm going say this in a way
that don't take me don't take this the
wrong way. Like we can kill a Malcolm,
we can kill a Martin. Then we can kill a
movement. But we can't kill him like
this. This powerful like because that's
a one-off. If I kill Malcolm, the
movement dies. I kill Martin, the
movement dies. Right? If I kill
whatever, the movement dies. for it
happen movement dies.
But I can't kill this. So in order to
kill this, I got to change the music.
You feel what I'm saying? Like I got to
change the music. How do I change the
music? All right. I got to get some
people out the hood that ain't never
seen a hundred million. That ain't never
seen a million dollars or 100,000
because everything they rap about is
poverty.
So what's the number one thing to get
somebody in poverty?
I want a way out.
So you give them $100,000, you give them
$50,000, and you write it in a way that
they don't know that they still a slave
to the system. But guess what you got
now? You got the Beamers, you got the
Benz, cuz we wasn't on Bentley's yet. We
wanted the Mercedes-Benz,
we wanted a BMW,
or we wanted the 5.0 Mustang,
right? If you in New York, you want the
Dappa Jan.
If you're in the south, you want the
eightball jacket and the Gucci jackets.
If you're in the West Coast, I don't
really know what they was on, so I don't
want really comment on them. I don't
really know what their style was,
you know what I'm saying? But I know
what top bottom was. You know what I'm
saying? And so, we got that. But also,
now look at now
at this point now in the 80s, I'm in my
40s,
right? But coming into I probably wasn't
in the stocks in I probably wasn't heavy
in it in 2010
but by time like I was still hustling
but by time that pandemic hit I was
locked in. I was ready like 2014 I was
ready. So by the time the pandemic hit I
was like boy I'm ready for this. You
know what I'm saying? So that that
generation there I'm not saying the 70s
generation wasn't on it but they
generation had a different fight. So
they was still locked in on get a good
job you know retire. My generation is
like, bro, like I don't even know if
that work.
Nothing against that generation. That
generation installed some principles in
us. The problem is now the next
generations, we got to start installing
the principles. So our generation is
like, "Hey y'all, like if you in your
40s, like 40, if you like 39, 40, 41,
you like, "Hey bro, that don't work."
The problem now is the younger
generation like they see it don't work
but now they done double down on the
music and they done double down on the
music so much now the music is just like
kill
like damn bro y'all killed goddamn
you know what I'm saying? So I think
that I want to see us win. So I'm not
mad at this stat.
I'm not mad at the stat. It gives us the
stat in totality. I understand the
premise of it. The premise is, hey, that
crap is down big.
I can endure
and I ain't mad at it. Let's go a little
further.
How's it going? Trap Jose, thank you so
much for taking my question. Huge salute
to the Patreon family, to the squad. My
name is Alex P, the Saiyan Trapper in
the Patreon group. And my question today
is about custodial accounts. Uh my son
turned three last week and my daughter's
going to turn one next month and that
got my wife and I thinking that we have
not set up their custodial accounts. We
do have their 529 open through Vanguard
as we've been setting or we've been
investing into their account so we can
set them up for college and educational
expenses in the future, but we do want
to uh start opening up their custodial
accounts. So my question is would you
recommend focusing more on lowcost
dividend paying ETFs like SCD or um
focusing more on individual stocks and
being a little bit more aggressive uh
with some of these stocks that we've
been talking in the Patreon. Again, they
have time which is the the benefit to
them and compound interest is going to
work in their favor. So uh just really
curious on your thoughts there.
appreciate you taking the time to answer
my question. And then real [snorts]
quick, just a huge shout out to you,
Rob, Jose, and just the entire squad for
everything you guys do. I joined the
mentorship uh at the end of last month
um and it's been phenomenal. I've
learned so much more than what I've
already been learning with you guys. But
the two days that we did um trading this
month, that was really eye opening. You
and Rob just really broke it down even
further um to where I could understand
it even better and it just just really
opened up my eyes. So, I thank you so
much for that. Huge salute to you guys.
Appreciate you, brother. Take care.
>> I think that's the best. We ain't never
get it like that, man. Shout out my dog
Alex P, man. Go Ali, man.
>> Come on, Alex P. [screaming]
Come on, bro.
>> Crazy.
>> Um, so I'll be honest with you. I I
personally I'mma say this like they one
and three. That's what he said, right?
One and three, right?
This gonna sound crazy as I don't know
what
at one and three. I would not vest
invest in a single index fund for them.
I would go fundamentals, great stock,
small position, add to it. I will put
money up every month or every week in
the account and then like in dips like
this I'm scaling in piece by piece. I
wouldn't go index fund. I wouldn't go
ETF unless it's a growth ETF like again.
But and the reason why I say that is
because they got time.
They got so much time. You don't got to
play it safe. You don't got to be ultra
aggressive. But you got to figure if he
won, if they won, you got 17 more years.
Three, 15 more years. Why are we playing
the safe?
Like, put them in a mix. That what I I'm
not going to lie. That what I did for my
daughter. Yo,
I did that for baby girl. She don't own
our one ETF, one index fund. We was
going We was going
Tesla when it was 10 and something.
We was going Netflix.
We've been She been in Netflix since
2019. [clears throat]
You know what I'm saying? Like I never
forget that. She was like, "Daddy, can I
own YouTube?" I was like, "Yep."
She was like, "Because I be watching
YouTube all the time." And I showed her,
I said, "That's Google right here." I
remember we got Google was dirt cheap
before they split the second time.
Like she been had Google since before
the pandemic. Like the pandemic, I'm not
going to lie. During the pandemic, I
loaded up. I don't think I loaded up
that much as I loaded up during that
pandemic. I ain't know what was ahead. I
was like, "Oh, I'm about to kill it for
I probably put about a 100 grand in her
account during the pandemic." No lie.
No lie.
During the Oh, no lie. No lie. I
remember I show her mama. She like,
"Where you get that money from?" I was
like, "Hey, chill out. Chill out. Chill.
Chill out." I've been playing I've been
crying broke for I don't know how long.
When it came to my daughter, when I saw
that moment, I was like, "Oh, this the
one." I remember even getting her watch
this crowd strike. I remember I bought
it for me at 57. I remember I bought it
for her like 63.
Yeah. Like Meta when Meta was $98 in
2022 when I was telling everybody, "Bro,
you should buy Meta." I bought her about
at least 20 $30,000 worth of Meta at
$97.
No lie.
No lie. No lie. Like
you have the opportunity where you don't
got to play it safe.
Because you thinking you thinking for
them in 15ear periods, not even like I'm
gonna be honest with you. I'm about to
say this. This about to go against
everything I want to happen right now.
You almost want the market to crash with
with with a with a one-year-old and a
three-y old. You almost like, bro,
crash.
Or you want to let it run up so you can
build your money up and then crash. So
you like, y'all can dump. So yeah, I'mma
be honest, Allan. Like I wouldn't go I
wouldn't go,
bro. My daughter I'm g say I'mma put
this out. My daughter got 2,000 shares
of Nvidia, bro.
My daughter got 2,000 shares of Nvidia,
bro. 100%.
100%,
bro. She got 2,000 shares of She might
got 25 if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah, bro. Yeah, bro. I'mma knock on
wood and I'mma say this and I shouldn't
say this loud, but I remember telling
myself, bro, like
if any if if God ever decided one day to
say, "All right, bro, like I want you to
start back over.
The only thing I would ask God is not to
let her have to start over."
You know what I'm saying? Like, let her
keep what I got for her right there.
Yeah. If you want me to get it out the
mud again, so be it. Like that's what it
is.
Cuz I know you going you going to get me
back where I was times 10. You wanted me
to learn a lesson. Just let me keep her
right there cuz that would make me go to
sleep good at night.
I go to sleep good good at night knowing
a couple things. One, we got a roof over
our head that we done paid for. And two,
she's sitting on what she's sitting on.
I've done my job as a father. Now all I
got to do is morally get her ready.
That's all I got to do.
So, so, so, so Alex, I I would not play
it safe with them. I would find a good
stock that's fundamentally good, that's
have a great return over the last 5
years, is up over 80% or more has price
and I would go in my move and you know,
and I'm not going to lie to you, it'll
be in technology, industrials, cyber
security. It will be stuff like that.
I'm not doing nothing safe. I don't care
about no dividends, none of that, bro. I
don't care about no dividends on my
daughter account. Like the one she do
got that's reinvested. We reinvested.
But I could care less about starting her
dividend account. She's straight. Let me
ask you a question, Jose, before we go
on to this. I had a conversation with my
daughter yesterday. Matter of fact, Miss
Arab, let me ask you a question. You and
Miss Janice over there. I had I had a qu
I had a conversation with my daughter
yesterday. We got in a truck yesterday.
We was driving. And so I I give her
these six pillars to live on.
I said, "You got to live on these six
pillars." And you got I've been telling
her to since she was three, maybe four,
maybe four. It's first God first,
lead with love,
respect,
honesty,
integrity, and accountability. Right?
That's our six pillars that we live on.
And she know what all of them mean. Um,
and then the next thing I always tell
her is
um,
no is a no is a complete sentence,
right? I say, I never want you to be a
people pleaser. She's like, what's a
people pleaser, daddy? So, this was
maybe like four years ago. I said,
people pleaser is somebody that tell
somebody yes because they worry about
how they feel and they don't want to
feel look a certain way to a person,
right? So, you you you please people and
put yourself at an inconvenience. you do
stuff that you don't really want to do.
I said, "So, you got to be cool with
telling people no." I said, "In the
moment," and I I told her, I said, "Be
quick to say no
and be slow to say yes."
I said, "Because it's easier to turn a
no to a yes than a yes to a no."
Because once you say yes to them, by you
don't put their hopes up high. If you
come back and say no, they're like,
"Damn, it's kind of like a bad feeling."
Cuz now you don't even feel right about
it. We can say no out the gate. I could
come back and say, "Hey, you know what?
I thought about let's do it." And if
they got somebody else in place already,
you're like, "All right, cool." Well,
so I always tell I say, "Look, be quick
to say no. Be slow to say yes." Like,
god your yeses
with your life.
Dish them nos out. Don't worry about how
people feel about it.
And so
I I started introducing this new concept
to like a year ago. I started saying you
got to protect your mind,
you got to protect your heart, and you
got to protect your body.
So, you got to protect your mind because
somebody can think for you, they can
lead you down a path you don't want to
go. You got [snorts] to protect your
heart because if you don't care about
your feelings, nobody will. And you got
to protect your body because that's your
temple and God gave it to you. So, I
tell her that, right? So, I introduced
this to her yesterday in the truck.
I said
I said look stank.
[laughter]
I said I said stank shut this off. She
like what's up daddy? I said you getting
to this age but you know like boys going
to start liking you.
I said
them [__] don't know [__] Excuse my
language. I said they don't like you.
They like the they gonna like the idea
of you.
I said I said if you don't have an idea
of who you are, you let somebody else
idea of you tell you who you are.
So I want you to know who you are. I say
God loves you. She say you I say you're
Leon Howard's daughter first and
foremost. You my daughter. You don't
need no you I I said think about how I
treat you. Think about how I talk to
you. Think about how you feel around me.
How I make you feel.
I said that's how I fall. That's how
love feels.
That's how love feels. I sacrifice. I do
anything for you. I I will not eat to
make sure you eat.
I will go naked to make sure you got
clothes on. I will I will sleep on the
floor to make sure you sleep in a bed.
That's my love for you.
There's no little boy at 8 years old or
10 years old that can love you like
that. There's no little boy at 15 that
can love you like that. There's no
little boy at 18 or 19 that can love you
like that.
So that this age of your life, don't let
love be the words that manipulate you.
Cuz every day I wake up, I show you I
love you. Every day I wake up that you
are the first thing on my mind after I
talk to God. I got to make sure you eat.
I gota make sure you got a roof over
your head. I gota make sure everything.
And then I got to teach you different
lessons. So our goal is to make sure
that you talk to God so God can lead you
in this journey. But my goal is to make
sure you can handle yourself a situation
where I'm not there.
So I said, "What do you tell a friend?"
I said, "Once you say no to a friend and
your friend say, but if you love me,
what do you say?" And she said, "If you
love me, you will respect my no." I
said, "Good." What do you tell a boy
that tells you the same thing?
And she said,
"If you think you love me, you will
respect my no." She said it so fast. She
said, "If you think you love me, you
will respect my nose." I said, I said,
"I'm good." So, I just want to keep
drilling that message because what I
understand in my life is I was a little
boy, bro,
>> man. And I I was a teenager
and I know
women don't know this. Let me say this.
All right, we gonna get back to the
stocks. Women don't know this.
As little boys because we don't we
aren't taught by men. We aren't taught
by the right men.
We learn how to be predatorial.
>> We learn how to look for the pretty girl
and say whatever is necessary to get the
pretty girl. Am I right, Aan?
>> Now your daddy right there. You better
watch what you say, boy.
>> Hold on. He know what I
>> was about to say. If you not if you not
raised domestically, you gonna be
predatorial by nature.
>> If you're not raised what?
>> If you're not raised domestically, you
will be
>> Hold up. Like I don't flush me yet.
Don't flush me.
>> If you're not raised domestically, if
you're not animals,
>> if you're not raised domestically,
naturally, you'll be predatorial. So
like for example, you see the lions that
be chilling with people and stuff and
they be like, "Well, wait, why you
chilling with this lion?" and D like
they have been trained to be around
people and stuff like that since a young
like you can't just find a wild lion and
chill with them. Can't do that. They
have to be trained up and be around and
be accustomed to that. So as young men
you have to be raised up and accustomed
to how to treat and who you are. If you
aren't,
>> you'll be wild.
>> For sure.
>> No, I got I got something else for you
though.
>> Why?
>> Cuz I had a daughter. I got a daughter.
>> You got a daughter? You got [snorts] a
daughter? I trained her up in those same
things.
>> Yeah.
>> I couldn't train her up as far as for
another another female.
>> Got it.
That's a totally different thing for a
phone.
>> Well, I ain't dealing with that.
>> Something else. Her mama got to talk to
>> Hey, her mom got to talk about
>> Yeah. But I feel like I feel like that
like as little boys like we train to be
like hunters.
>> You know what I'm saying? Like cuz you
got to think about it like as little
boys like you under peer pressure early.
>> Mhm.
>> To have sex.
>> Well, you still a virgin, bro. I ain't
no virgin. You lying like I'm a
>> Yep.
>> You know what I'm saying? man, you you
you under that pressure as a little boy
and and you think it's cool because you
ain't never had nobody tell you, "Hey,
bro, they ain't really cool with Arab."
Like, don't do that, bro. Like, now I
would raise my son a completely
different way. Now, if I had a son, I
would raise him completely different. I
would I would tell him like, "Look at
your sister. Look at your mother, bro.
Like, we want to treat all women like
you would treat your sister or your
mother." Like, we ain't doing that. You
know what I'm saying? But we know that a
lot of little and that's still going on
where little. So we I feel like it's my
job to prepare her for what she about to
face. Now how she handle it, I can't do
nothing with that, but I won't equip her
with the tools to know how to navigate
that space.
>> All right, let's move on.
>> That was good.
>> Like we've been having our little
therapy sessions.
>> Let's try to make it a real life show,
man.
>> You know, trap of the week. Let's go,
man. Our trap of the week is William S.
Pitman. William S. Pitman. um was an
African-American architect educated.
Hold up, Miss Abram. What you think
about it?
I I said it, but I left you alone and
come talk to Jose and Ashan who called
us domesticated.
What you think about it, Miss April?
I'mma holl at you, man. [laughter]
>> She said he did a good job.
>> All right.
Couple
>> couple little tweets.
>> Couple little tweets. All right. William
Sydney Pitman was an African-American
architect, educator, entrepreneur, and
publisher who became one of the earliest
prominent African-American architectures
in the United States. He's especially
what that word is I can't see it.
He remembered because the the R is
chopped off. Remembered as the first
practicing black architect in Texas and
as the first African-American architect
to receive a federal agricultural
commission. Let's go a little further
into this.
>> Sydney Pitman studied architecture at
Tuskegee under Robert Robinson Taylor.
He then earned his degree from Drexel
Institute in Philadelphia, becoming one
of the most formally trained black
architects in the country. In 1907,
Pitman won a federal competition to
design the Negro building at the
Jamestown Centennial Exposition, the
first federal architectural contract
ever awarded to a black American. The
building showcased black achievement in
education, business, and the arts to a
national audience. But Pitman's career
was marked by constant frustration.
Despite his credentials and his family
connections, major commissions were
routinely denied to him. White firms
received the contracts. Black architects
were confined to the black comm. Goodman
died in 1958.
Today, many of his buildings have been
demolished. The Negro building at
Jamestown, the first federally
commissioned structure designed by a
black architect, was temporary. It no
longer exist.
>> How do we feel about that, Jose?
I was I actually got caught up in the
chat so I get to watch that whole D, you
know, and then also the first two
pictures look like I didn't look like
the same Pitman.
>> That ain't I think that because one of
them was younger and then one of them
was a little older.
>> Yeah. And
>> I felt like the hell you got.
>> Yeah. Then I was in the I was in my bag
about how they edited that with the AI.
So I was just I was in production mode
like yo, why they do my man like that?
Somebody said that voiceover sound like
a Harry Potter one.
Y'all are crazy, man. All right, let's
go a little further, man.
All right, who owns the market? Watch
this, y'all. The wealthiest 1% um of US
earners now own 50.1% of US equities and
mutual funds. Right, their ownership
stood at their ownership stood at 40.1%
in 1990 and 39.6% 6% in 2020 2001. The
next 9% wealthiest household own 37.3%
of equities. Right? The middle class own
40%. The middle the middle 40% own 11%
and the bottom 50% earners hold just
1.1%.
Right? So ownership of the top 1% over
1990 to 2020 and now 50%. As a result,
the top 10% of American earners now own
87.4% of all equity and mutual fund
assets.
Watch this key word right here. This key
phrase I'm about to say,
asset owners are the only winners in
this economy.
Say that again.
Asset owners are the only winners in
this
economy.
Let's go a little further. And the
reason why I say this because I don't
care like I don't care where y'all at.
So let me let me say this to everybody,
bro.
The market going to go through seasons.
I don't care if you're a day trader. I
don't care if you're a swing trader.
I don't care what you trade.
You going to go through a season,
man. My my dog Toby in the chat.
Ah, [screaming]
my brother in the chat.
Let's go my brother in the chat. Give me
the beat. Give me the beat. Give me the
beat.
[singing]
God
>> my nigger's [music and singing]
heart. [chanting]
>> Oh,
>> I'mma tell y'all something, bro. You
know when you know when somebody really
love you, bro? Like, cuz I'm the same
way, bro. Like when somebody called me
and I got access to something, it's
never hold on
it.
So like Terica called me and she needed
something. I said, "Hold on. I got you."
I called to the day. I said, "Hey, bro.
I need group chat right there." Boom.
Hey, get trapped. What he need right
here. CJ saying get with bro. I love
that type of action, bro.
I love that type. I remember my dog. I
said, "Thob you got to get the kids in
the in the um in the stock market, bro."
He said,
"Say less. Come on. Let's go. Let's do
it." No. He said, "Son," I said, "No,
no, no, no." He said, "All right, I'm
going do I said, "No, no, no, no. Let's
do it now. I'm in my crib. I'm chilling.
I ain't really doing nothing." We did
like two accounts. He was like, "Char,
that's a lie."
I said, "Let's do Let's do it piece by
piece." You know what I'm saying? Same
thing with CJ. See, I said, "See, you
got to get the kids in the market, bro."
He said, "Bet. Say less." When I'm
pulling up, I'm like, "I'm here now."
He's like, "I'm doing something next to
him and Candace pull it up." Like I like
like I'm not the friend. Like I don't
call a lot of people friend.
But bro, like
I love that cuz that's my type of time.
My type of time is Hey,
you know what I'm saying, bro? Like
that's a different
Shout out to my brother to man. Shout
out to my brother Toad, bro. It's like,
all right, so I'm g say this though. Any
like I don't care what I don't care what
type of So like like the guy say earlier
about day trade. Cool. But guess what?
Even day traders lose.
Day traders lose. Leap traders lose.
Swing traders lose. You know what I love
more than any of that? you playing the
game.
That's the thing that matters more to
me.
Yes, there's a learning curve in the
game, but you're playing
the game
and that's what matters to me.
So, I'm not gonna lie. When I see the
wealthiest 1% on that and I see the
bottom 50% of earners only own just 1%
of equities, in my mind, I'm like, "All
right, bet. How can we shift that
number?" Because, watch this. The key
word in there is earners.
The key word in that is earners. Now, we
already know who the lowest earners
going to always be. It's going to always
be people that living in, you know,
certain neighborhoods, certain areas,
but that don't mean they still can't
increase their wealth, their asset
ownership.
Does that make sense? Like, I understand
that you a low earner. We can work on
that, but that still don't mean we can't
increase your asset ownership.
Come on, man. Listen to what I'm saying
here, y'all.
Like, you can be a person like a low
earn is somebody that's probably making
I don't know. Anywhere between
I don't know because I don't want to put
no numbers out there and sound crazy.
But you know you ain't in a 1%.
And you know you probably ain't in a 9%.
So if you between anywhere between the
middle and the bottom percent,
you know one thing.
I I gotta increase my earnings. That's
cool.
But I can still make a lot out of what I
have,
right? Like I can still be saying, "All
right, I may be in the 1%. I'mma change
that. But even though I'm in the 1%, I'm
investing 1% of this paycheck."
Because all we want to do is increase
our asset ownership.
That's what we want. Increase.
So, let's let's go a little further than
that, Jose.
All right. Americans feel paycheck. Oo.
Americans feeling a paycheck squeeze.
Middle class living paycheck to
paycheck. 64%
of a people with income between 50,000
to 99,000 a year living paycheck to
paycheck. 41% of people with incomes of
a 100,000 to 249,000 are living paycheck
to paycheck. And I say this on my
webinar. I say there's a difference
between broke and poor. And neither one
of it has anything to do with
financials.
So watch this. Broke is I don't know
what to do with my money. Poor is I
don't have the information about money.
Broke is I don't know what to do with
money. So you have you have improper you
money usage,
right? When you broke, you have improper
money usage. Watch this. And that don't
matter how much you make.
When you're poor, you don't have the
information on money usage.
It has nothing to do with the money
itself.
You know why it don't have nothing to do
with the money itself? Because when we
grew up, we didn't know that we was
poor.
We thought everybody had powdered eggs.
We thought everybody ate, you know what
I'm saying? Like what? Yo, what y'all
got today? Egg and rice. Bet. Send me
something. I want something. What y'all
got? We good with that? Y'all got the
baloney sandwich. The baloney flip up
like a little dome
>> and everybody the dome.
>> I was thinking,
>> come on. The baloney pop like a dome
that the size of it be burnt.
>> Oh my god,
>> bro. What you talking about here?
We ain't know that was poor.
We ain't know that, bro.
>> Them oodles or noodles?
>> Come on, bro. What?
>> Powder eggs. We didn't know that was
poor. But man, you tripping. What y'all
got when we got them powdered eggs, boy?
I'm about to bust them things up.
>> I used to think rich
>> syrup sandwiches. About to bust that up,
bro.
>> Rich was the cup of noodles. When you
got to the cup of noodles with the
little plastic, I said, "Oh, we rich."
>> Bro, my grandma had beans on top of
beans on top of beans on top of beans in
New Orleans. Boy,
>> pinto beans, black beans, white beans,
red beans,
beans on top of beans. We don't know
what poor is. It until you get old, you
be like, "Wait a minute.
I'm broke."
Wait, I'm broke. You ain't know that
coming up, bro. You ain't even think you
was poor when you had to wear the same
Like, bro, I know me. Like, coming up
before we my grandmother moved to a
certain area, I had two pair of uh two
pair of um school dickies.
I had to wear one pair one day and
Tuesday. I had to wear the other pair
Wednesday and Thursday and I had to hand
wash the ones I wore Monday and Tuesday
so they could be ready for Friday.
I used to run them dickies cuz we had
beautiful
>> and then in the summertime I only got
two pair of shorts. That's it. This got
to last you boy all year, man. I'm not
thinking I'm poor.
>> Dickies was like dress clothes,
>> bro. You not thinking like that. You get
a pair of shoes when? In the beginning
of school,
probably some type of holiday. You only
getting three pair of shoes.
>> Mine was in the summer. So, I ain't had
that privilege.
You getting three pair of shoes, bro.
You get one during the Christmas break
and get one school first start and
somewhere either in the middle or toward
the end. That better work, bro. That
better work.
You feel what I'm saying? You get a hole
in those pants, boy, you getting a
patch.
Ain't no such thing as new pants.
>> He laughing. He ain't never had the Aan
ain't never had the patch, man.
>> Ain't never had a patch. Boy, I had the
patch.
>> We had the patch.
>> Know why? Cuz I'm playing pitchup tackle
in school. I'm running around. I slide.
I got to go home. Mama, I got a hold of
my pants. Go put that Go iron that patch
on there.
>> Iron that thing on.
>> Come on. We ain't look at that as no
pour. Cuz the same person trying to rip
me got a hole in the sock.
He got his socks folded cuz he wants
some ankle socks.
>> He got the fake.
>> Somebody try to rip me. Take your shoes
off.
>> Fake ankle socks.
>> Take your shoes off. Take my man. Don't
take your shoes off. He take the shoe
off. The sock doing this. Stop playing
with me, boy. Stop playing with me, boy.
>> You tell me I got a hold of my pan. Why
you got that tube sock tucked like that?
All your foot tight in the shoe cuz
that's an eight and a half. You put the
Once the shoe tucked like that, it's a
10. You supposed to have a tin on with
the T. Stop playing me. I'm cold blooded
at ripping. But this the thing. We
didn't look at that as poor.
>> Yeah.
[laughter]
>> Come on. Am I lying?
>> No, you on it. I was cold blooded, too,
but I was I was like a sniper.
>> Come on, man. When the elastic in the
pants start getting cool, I know my
grandma wasn't doing that. Guess what I
did? Rubber band me, please.
>> Mhm.
>> Rubber band me. Rubber bandh.
Pull it up a little bit so it can look I
got the elastic, partner. Stop playing.
Stop playing. You know how you know it
ain't the real elastic? Because it fold
over. It start looking like a mushroom.
You're [laughter]
>> Oh, you going deep.
>> I'm just saying we didn't know that was
poor, bro.
>> No belt string. Got string.
>> I flipping mine. Putting a shirt over
it. Come on. We didn't know that was
poor, bro.
I'm here to tell us that it don't got
nothing to do with money.
Broke,
I don't have the tools on how to use
money, right? Poor, I don't have the
information. It has nothing to do with
money. Because if your mind, you can
say, "Bro, how can somebody make 50,000
to $100,000 a year and still live check
to check?" It don't have nothing to do
with the money.
How can somebody make a hund listen you
saying yeah I get a try somebody making
$100,000 to $249,000
41% of them live check to check
but if they downgrade it
take the bins out the driveway
take the the the all the house you need
out the driveway
take the super expensive furniture out.
Bro, I'm going to be real with you. I
just told myself, bro, we about to stop
door dashing so much. Bro, I started,
bro. I cooked a meal for I've been
cooking for me and my daughter.
>> Mhm.
>> Man, we not doing that no more, man. I'm
straight. For the next two weeks you
here, we cooking food, fam.
>> She get in there, cook us some pancakes
and stuff in the morning. I cook us
dinner at night.
You can eat fruits and stuff during the
day. She eat noodles during the day. I
ain't tripping on that. All right, let's
go a little further. That's my little
rant for that though. Let's go a little
further. Stop letting Instagram tell you
you poor and you broke.
We be on a webinar, bro. We on a
webinar, but they got people that's 26
years old say they feel behind. How the
hell you feel behind at 26?
What you behind?
>> Watching everything on Tik Tok.
>> What you tell me what you behind at 26.
That 26, bro. I was stepping foot out
the pin like ah I'm outside
$3,500 to my name.
First thing I went did, bought a uh uh
what that car was? A a GTC. It was a
Grand Prix. Call me $3,500. No license,
no nothing.
Had a gift of gas. Hey, bro. Is
>> that the joint George be talking about?
>> Huh?
>> Is that the joint George be talking
about?
>> That I wrecked?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, we we had to pull up to the
dealership [laughter]
cuz the tire come off.
>> Oh, yeah. When I pull up with the burn
and everything, hey bro, come out that
thing, boy. [laughter]
I got George with me like, "Come out of
there." I'm like, "Hey, come out of that
boy." Saw my hand behind my back. I
don't know what I thought I was hiding
like this. [laughter]
Clearly, you got something.
What's that? What that? I said, "Hey,
come out of that pan
got the AR in the truck." You like,
"Come up." Like, "Hey." He like
No, like I'm talking about I'm on the
interstate. The wheel come off. Boom.
Boom. I'm like, wait, hold up. That's
the wheel. [laughter]
On the interstate.
Oh, somebody about to get it.
He said,
>> I ain't had that thing 45 days.
He said, "Oh, that's [laughter]
I'm driving this thing." I just see the
I see the car I hit. I'm like, that's a
hell of a bump I just hit. I see the
wheel look bump bump. I said, "Wait,
that look like mine."
>> It's next to you. Your wheel driving
next to you is
>> Wait, that thing come jumping on the
interstate. B, that thing hopping on
interstate.
[laughter]
>> I'm driving a car like that's a hell of
a pothole out here. But wait, there
potholes on the interstate. I said, man,
that look like mine.
Oh, [groaning]
about to die.
I call Jo. I say, "Hey, K." He said,
"What's up?" I said, "Man, get the
sticks.
I'm going back." That was my last 35.
[laughter]
I'm going to the booth. I'm going to the
>> I'm going back.
>> Oh, man. My bad, bro. My bad, bro. I
apologize.
Anyway, Americans feeling a paycheck
squeeze, paycheck divide by income. 81%
income less than 50% 12% income um less
than 250,000. Let's go a little further.
[snorts]
Americans feeling squeeze. Middle class
financial stressors. These are the
stressors they're saying for the middle
class. Credit card debt, auto insurance,
medical bills. So, how do we help that?
So, this is one of the things I told
people before like you got to be able to
bring that credit card debt down, y'all.
And the thing about credit card debt is
it don't feel like you really spending
money cuz you swiping. And that's the
whole trick behind it.
That's the whole trick behind it.
>> Yeah, them interest joints and
everything. That's
>> the whole trick behind it is cuz think
about this though. I read a stat that
said that like I want to say since the
pandemic, 90% of the money that's being
spent is digital. Meaning it did not
even exist.
So you know digital money don't exist.
Credit card money don't exist. It don't
exist until you pay it.
It don't. That's the purpose of the car.
>> Backed by a contract on paper.
>> It's backed by a contract that you
signed. The money don't exist.
So you paying you're paying
how I want to say this?
You're you're buying something based on
the card.
The card is the what do I want to say
here
is the the card is the
what it is
>> I won't use another terminology but
that's it that's essentially it like the
card is necessarily the uh the verific
like you you're verified to use this
like the card is the guarantee it's the
card that's giving you the okay but the
money don't exist until you pay for it.
Not even when you spend it. Cuz watch
this. If you spend on a credit card and
then go bankrupt, you don't owe it.
The money don't exist until you pay it.
>> I got you right now, Jose.
>> When you said the bankruptcy situ, I'd
be like, dang, you getting out like, oh,
>> think about it, bro. Wipe that clean.
>> Think, man, wipe that clean. I don't owe
nobody.
The car, the money don't exist until you
cash out and pay for it. That's why they
got to put pressure on people when you
don't pay the car. Here's how you know
it don't exist.
If you don't pay your credit card bill
and let's say they drop your credit
score, you be like, "So what? I don't
even care."
They then watch this. They let's say you
owe $20,000.
They'll sell that $20,000 debt to
somebody for $3,000.
>> Yep.
And then tell them, "Go get the 20." But
they cool with the They cool with it cuz
in their mind, if they can just get you
on any type of payment plan, if they can
get 5,000 of the 3,000, they won.
>> Day one, it's a win.
>> So the money don't exist until you pay
it.
Come on. I'm smoking y'all right now,
bro.
I'm smoking y'all right now, bro.
It don't exist. Now, I'm not saying that
it's not a But that's why we go back and
say it's a what? Stressor. Because in
our, you know, we like, damn, bro. Like,
damn, I owe this money. [clears throat]
That's why people don't like going in
debt because it's a stressor.
Bro, when I got this building, the first
thing I say was, "All right, bro." Like,
"Shit, I'm about to go $4 million in
debt."
I do not like how that sound.
I don't care if I got the money, don't
got the money. I do not like how $4
million in debt sound.
All right, let's come up with an idea to
No, when you when you file bankruptcy,
you clean. Now, that goes against you
because like, hey, you done filed
bankruptcy. But guess what? That's what
wealthy people do all the time. Now,
there's a difference between chapter 7
and chapter 11. It's two different types
of bankruptcy, but it's actually three
or four different kinds, but chapter 7
and 11 is the most known ones. So, they
both mean something different.
All right, I ain't going to get it.
That's a whole another class. All right,
let's go a little further, man.
All right, so Eli, [snorts] perfect
segue. betting you on your job right
now, boy. Perfect segue. Money won't
matter in 2036, says Elon Musk. Do you
think that's a bold prediction or not,
Jose?
>> Super Bowl, bro. But everything we've
been talking about been leading to that
like we were talking about before and
then even Sean was like, "Oh, they
always printing money. Why don't you
just print some more?" The money ain't
worth nothing. It's going to be worth
nothing. So, yeah, I agree with him,
dog, cuz think about this.
So watch this. I'm going to tell you
something I found out.
So you know every time you go use a car
right now, what happen when you go use a
car?
When you go use your credit card
somewhere, let's say you go to
Starbucks, let's say you go to um Burger
King, McDonald's, you go to any joint,
when you use your car, what do they do?
They ask you, they're going to ask you a
question. No, you ask me for a tip.
You're not asking me a question. you're
asking me for a tip. But if you go with
cash, they don't ask you for the tip.
If you go to Starbucks
or you go to any place where you can use
your card, a smoothie or whatever, and
you say you paying cash a car, you say,
"I'm paying with car." Say, "Okay, first
I'm going to ask you a little question
first." It's not a question. It's a tip.
Do you want tip 5%, 10%, 20, whatever?
Right? But if you go pay cash,
you don't get to ask no question.
>> Huh?
>> He said they still got the jar
[laughter]
>> that they don't even present the jar.
>> It's just there.
>> They don't be like, "Hey, answer the
question. [laughter]
>> I ain't pay for cash in a long time,
bro." So
>> I do that intentionally now, bro.
>> You know why? because it's hard for them
to ask you for a tip.
It's easier for you to press the card.
Most people just because you paying with
it automatically, you gonna press the
tip anyway. Watch this. Not many people
going to press no.
If 10 people go, two people might say
no.
>> Mhm. And they start at 15.
>> And here's how I knew that was a gimme
for the company because I had people
say, "Hey, if you going to tip me, just
tip me in cash. Don't tip me on the
thing,
>> right? Cuz now they adding it as wages
and all this other stuff. Crazy.
>> I'm saying that to say that like a lot
of places we going now, they're
cashless.
>> Come on, man. I took y'all on a whole
journey just now in two minutes. Bro,
>> a lot of places we going now are
cashless because they can do little
subtle things on the card to get more
money out.
Notice they'll ask you for a tip and
then ask you if you want to donate. If
you go to Publix or somebody like that,
they'll say, "Hey, would you do a tip?"
You be like, "I'm good." Okay, next
question. Do you want to donate? Bro,
you just double whamming me.
>> Mhm. I don't know where that going.
>> If you go to Sprouts, guess what they
do? 10 cent for a bag. Wait, why I got
to pay y'all 10 cent for a bag?
So, the bag not included.
[snorts]
Where these rules come from?
Because it's easier to make you pay more
with the card, bro. You're not going to
say, "Nah, I don't want that 10 cent."
But if you got your cash, you'll be
like, "Nah, I'm straight. Let me get
that. I'm I'mma carry it."
>> I'm telling you, bro.
>> Oh, no. You good. Look, I only can use
one card now. The wife got me down.
>> But I'm just saying
>> like
>> a lot of things, bro. Come with you. Use
your car.
>> Cuz it's easier for you to spend money.
It don't. Watch this. Another example
for you.
If you had $200 in your pocket and I
say, "Ra, give me $50."
You got to physically go in your pocket.
Now you going to look at it. Damn, I
only got $200.
Before you give me the 50, you start
calculating like, damn.
>> Or you got to ask somebody, can they
break it?
>> And guess what?
>> I don't want to break my bills.
I literally told somebody that before,
man, I ain't got it, bro. I don't want
to break my hundreds. I'm straight. But
if you got a car, I say, "Rob, zel me
50."
You should get on your phone. There's no
there's no there's no feeling for it.
I send my dog 50,
man. Send me a quick 20 right quick. But
I mean, it comes across as convenient.
If I got to go in my pocket and get that
cash though, it's like, how much that
cost?
But if I'm swiping the card,
I'm cooking y'all tonight cuz y'all
ain't even giving me credit for how much
I'm cooking right now. I'm in I'm in a
>> Come on, man. I got this fried rice
going crazy in this walk cuz [screaming]
>> Come on, man.
>> That's good.
>> Tripping over here.
>> Well, right. Let's run that last D. This
is something for you then. Let's go.
>> Wow. What's going on, family? Shout out
to the big brother trap. Appreciate Jose
for taking my call. All my brothers and
sisters in the faith and in the
community of the Wall Street Travel,
baby. I'm new, brand spanging new. I
just hopped off the webinar a couple
days ago. I dropped two bands on the
package you had going. I did do the
payment plan, but it was tripping.
But I said, man, you know what? I'm
blessing Holl. I make that back.
>> Um, but real quick, man, you know, um,
brother to brother, New Orleian to New
Orleian, you feel me? Um, I did a little
juice myself. 12 years. I've been home
18 months. been blessed to be able to
stack my bridge, you know, stack the
nice, but I just got the money sitting.
Old school, old law. So, um, I need
help, brother. But I would like to know
this, though. What's your greatest, most
valuable, intangible asset? I need to
know that. Love you, brother. Appreciate
y'all taking my call.
>> Hey, bro. Let me tell you something,
bro.
I know us when I hear us, bro.
And we such. So I'm going tell you
something. This listening to him let me
know that I inherited this trait from
being in New Orleans.
We will tell a story before we get to
what we need to say.
But you got to hit a story cuz if you
don't hit a story then what I say don't
have as much like pop to it. You know
what I'm saying? I think that's a New
Orleans thing, bro. like I got to tell
you and it ain't going to take long, but
I got to just get into the story before
I ask you the question. I do it all the
time up here.
Shout out to that. So, my greatest uh
so, first of all, salute to you, bro,
for
um for for doing the Jo and coming home
and getting to it, bro. And I'm I always
say this to people like I have a biased
love
for dudes who did a stretch and come
home and like won't get it right.
I'm I'm I'm 100% biased toward that.
No hate, no nothing. is just I'm biased
toward it because I know the type of
I know what we fighting internally and
externally to make that decision to say
this what I want to do. So, uh my
greatest intangible asset
>> Wait, why you think about it? Shout out
to him for joining the mentorship just
off of the webinar.
>> Oh, got to do that. He got he got the
mentorship. Yo, that's I mean that's
dope for that. Then I ain't tripping.
Like that's why we created a payment
plan for it so people can take advantage
of it and still be like bro like it
ain't no pressure. And I like he says he
say bro I'm blessed and highly favor. I
know I'm going to get that back. Like
that's what I like to hear. Like cuz
that's my goal. Like my goal is like bro
we gonna get that back. We gonna get all
that whatever you paid for that we gonna
get that back. So my greatest
intangible asset
in case y'all don't know what intangible
means. Something you can't touch.
something you can't touch.
Um, I think I would say my greatest
intangible asset is
at this point in my life,
I'm learning to appreciate the present.
And so, you may feel like, man, that
ain't really what I want to hear.
Um, the reason why I say that is good
because there's no greater there's no
greater asset than time.
There's no there's no greater miss
what the word I want to use here.
There's no greater
there's nothing more underappreciated
than the present.
And so one of the things I'm learning
and that has that wouldn't have always
been my answer.
The reason why I can say that now is
because I'm learning how now to
appreciate
the present. No matter what it is, I'm
I'm learning like to and like even
yesterday being able to just like get in
the truck, go with my daughter. We
really just went in the park and ran
around.
We played it.
That's what we played. And I looked down
and I'm not saying it's like I had a
pair of Christian Diors on. My daughter
had a pair of Tims on. We got on a swing
first and I was like, "All right, let's
let's see who swing the highest." So,
I'm in a swing and she's swinging so
high. You know, when you swing so high,
the swing start buckling. Boom. Boom.
I'm like, "Damn, she's swinging higher
than me." So, I start swinging a little
high and I'm 45. I'm like, "Wait a
minute. It's a little too high. Once I
buckle two times, I was like, "Wait,
this too high." So, I had to I had to
switch the game up a little bit. I let
it come down a little bit. I said, "I
bet you can't do this." I jump out the
swing. Ah, you know what I'm saying? And
they had the little They had the little
like mushy ground
>> with the little stuff. Yeah.
>> So, it didn't But I was in that moment.
I was in that moment with my baby. And
we went to running playing it and she
start cheating because our touch she
like I had my fingers crossed.
I'm like what part of the game that is
right? And then you know when I did it
she like no you can't do that. So just
appreciating the present. The other day
we was playing Monopoly being present.
The other day before that we playing Uno
being present. She wanted to watch
Scream 7 like all right bet we watch the
Scream 7. So for me it's like in this
season
being present is my greatest intangible
asset because I'm appreciating the time.
I don't know what it is about now that
I'm saying and I'mma say this like at 44
like you at the top of the hill.
At 44, you got to think the average
person lives to 70. At 44, 73, 74, I'm
past the midway point.
Just being realistic. I'm past the mid
the average person lives to see 70 72 or
76. I'm past the midway point.
Now, of course, I want to live way past
that, but I just want to appreciate the
time now.
I won't appreciate the moments.
You know what I'm saying? So like if I
can say anything to you, brother, it
would be like on this journey,
appreciate the moments. Appreciate the
small wins you going to get along the
way. Like one of the things I got, my
phone is pregnant with moments.
And I'll go on my phone like I just did
this the other day, bro. I literally
went in my phone and looked at every day
I was in Italy and relived them laying
in my bed like, "Damn, that felt good.
Damn, that was cool right there. Damn."
Oh. And then the the dude who owned the
hotel, who gave me his number, he hit me
up on Instagram today. He was like,
"Man, how everything going? How you
been? What's up?" I was like, "Man, I'm
chilling, man." He like, "Man, you got
to come back to Capri." I'm like, "Trust
me, I'm coming. He like, "This time you
come back, I'm going to take you with
me. We going to have a blast. I'm going
to take you out. I'm going to show you
some local stuff. I'm going to do some
stuff." I'm like, "All right." He owned
the hotel and the restaurant. Treating
me amazing.
And it's just like
we can get
we can get so caught up in and I've been
there. We can get so caught up in the
trying to achieve my goals.
Man, Pastor Don told me something last
night that was so good, bro.
He said, and I want to make sure I say
this right. He said,
we can focus so much on a problem and
forget God's provision.
I said, what?
He said, "Sometimes we can get so
focused on the problem
and forget God's provision."
Meaning,
sometimes we can get so caught up on,
you know, whatever the problem is,
whatever we trying to fix, whatever we
trying to solve, whatever it is after,
and we forget that
God gonna take care of it anyway
if we let him.
Our biggest issue for us as men,
especially I can't speak for women, I
can speak for men because a lot of men
have this trait, is because we feel like
a lot of men, not all men, a lot of men,
we feel like if we not providing, we
feel less than.
It's why a lot of men go to jail.
selfish as it is, we'll do some crap
that put our freedom at stake, put our
life at stake under the guise of I'm
trying to protect my family and I got to
feed my family. And you're not wrong,
but you're not right.
A lot of pressure that we as men have
is the provider pressure.
And when you become a certain
when you become a certain
income earner
that providing pressure doesn't decrease
it increases
until you find a way to not let the
money be the master but be the slave.
So when Jose said his girl was like
checking his accounts I wasn't mad at
that. In my mind, I'mma tell you what I
really said.
That's some good [__] right there.
And it made me realize I haven't looked
at a bill in my house in three years.
All I know is how much my mortgage cost,
bro.
>> All I know is I pay
>> double digits on autopay.
>> Everything else on autopay.
I don't know what the light bill is. I
don't know what the internet bill is. I
don't know what the electrician bill is.
I don't know what the water bill is. I
don't know what nothing I don't know how
much it cost us to put food in the
house. I don't know none of that.
>> Exact same.
>> I don't know none of that. And so when I
I was like, damn, I need to put that on.
I need to start I need to start doing
it. I need to know how much it cost me
to live in my house outside of what I
pay on the mortgage, outside of what I
pay on the insurance. What am I paying
these people to come clean this pool
every week? What am I paying these lawn
care people every week? I don't even
know how much I pay my therapist.
It's on auto pay.
All I know is when I don't go to her one
week, I just hope she don't charge me
that week. But she good people, so she
ain't going to play me like that. But I
don't know how much I pay her. I like
when I go I go to the dentist every
month.
>> Same. Don't even know.
>> I go to the dentist every month, bro.
And the reason I go is because I got hit
with a lock in my bottom part of my
mouth. So the bottom part of my teeth
will get really yellow if I don't get
them cleaned. I don't know why, but
it'll get really yellow if they don't
get clean. So, I got to go every month
because I'm always in people's face. You
know what I'm saying? So, but like other
than that, bro, like I don't know.
I don't know. So, when Ashley did that,
it made me like, wait, I got to start
doing that.
>> And it was so much we just
>> I need to start doing that. Like, I need
to go I need to look at, you know,
Rocket Money and see like what
subscriptions I'm paying that I really
don't even use no more. And when you got
multiple bank accounts,
>> multiple stuff just coming out of
everywhere.
>> Yeah, bro. So you got leaky hoes, bro.
And so now when Ash did that to you, I
was like, "Yeah, I'm going to go back to
saying that though." Like as men, we
such providers, bro. And so much of who
we are as men is tied to providing.
Very seldom. And I'm not going to say
this for all men. I'mma speak from my
own experience. And it may not be true.
Let me lead with this. This may not be
true. Let me leave with this again. This
may not be true. There's a part of me
that felt like this. I don't honestly
know if I can say like, damn,
have I ever really like
like when it come to investing, I know
where my money at.
When it come to taking care of my
daughter, I know where that money at.
But have I ever really like
guarded my money like that? I don't
know, bro.
All I know is I look at my bank account
at least once a week to see like what's
going on. I look at what I got to pay my
people in my business. But like I'm not
g and I think I was so proud of you when
Ashley did that because I was like bro
that's a woman that's coming in your
life saying here's structure [__]
cuz let you you would have been like I
don't care like the pro presenter we got
to use it. I ain't tripping. She like no
no no that's taken from the church.
>> That's one of
>> No no no for sure
>> 30.
>> Yeah that's for sure. It's stuff that
you've been paying that you ain't even
like all right bet but in your mind be
like where my money going at
>> and when you add it up I was like
>> right. So like that's one of the dope
things like the right woman going to do
and not and it made sense to me why
certain men I worked on a job they were
like yo I'm going to give my girl the
money.
She add structure.
So there has [laughter] to be a balance
between you going hunt
and she making sure we eat. Two
different things.
>> You got two different things. You got
that walk going, boy.
>> I'm going to go hunt. She going to make
sure we eat. She going to make sure the
roof stay over our head. She going to
make sure everything is in order. And
she going to question certain stuff
like, "What you spending money on this
for? What you spending money on that
for? What you doing this for? What you
doing that for? What you doing this
for?" And in your mind, you like, "Man,
I don't know. I just wanted you to be
straight." Like, I just No, that ain't
us being straight. Us being straight
making sure, watch this. Like, us being
straight making sure you stay a
millionaire as till you die.
to me. Like that's the type of like
I'm at this phase. Like I want that.
Like I want that woman to be like, "No,
no, no. You good. I ain't tripping on
your bread." Like I like some of the and
I like some of the perks that come with
it, but I won't have this till we die.
So I'm telling my guy right now, like, I
like the space you in. You know, you've
been home 18 months. You you killing it,
bro. Like,
and it goes back to me with the time.
the time matters because I want to
appreciate these moments.
You know what I'm saying? I won't
appreciate where I'm at right now, but I
won't appreciate everything I'm going
through. I won't appreciate the what
it's going to take. Pastor Don told me
something the other night. He said, "The
gold is a hundred million trap for you.
But what if the hundred million is just
a metaphor for the $100 million man you
got to become? Not from a financial
perspective, but a hundred million
dollar father, a hund00 million husband,
a hundred million dollar CEO that can
lead his team, a hundred million dollar
friend, $100 million son. I was like,
damn. He said, so what if the hundred
million is not even a is not even a
dollar thing, but it's a metaphor for
who you have to become in all these
different areas of your life. And I was
like, damn, bro,
that's so good.
And that's why to me like spiritual
mentorship is so important for me in
this phase of my life because I know
I've been off my Dean a little bit.
All right y'all we going to end the show
on that tonight y'all. We end the show
on that.
>> That was good. That was good.
>> We going to end the show on that. We
going to end the show on that tonight.
>> Let's go. I got the watch. [laughter]
>> You ain't giving me my props over here
cuz you crazy. I'm out here. I'm falling
out the chair. I'm running around the
the joint. Everybody here like it ain't
in a library.
>> Let's go, man. All right, y'all. So, um
my Patreon people, I'mma be in the chat
tomorrow, y'all. I got y'all. My travels
and honors people, I'mma be in the chat
tomorrow, y'all. Like, I thank y'all for
just giving me the um
for giving me the grace these last two
days. I know some people probably left
like, "Man, Trap ain't been here for a
couple days. I'm about to leave." Like,
I get it. Like, some, you know, some
stuff been happening and I I've been
having to take care of that. Um, I try
my best to take care of it. Um, other
than that, man, look, come join the
Patreon, man. It's a vibe up in there.
You know, I'm myself, Rob. We're going
to help us navigate this the way we're
supposed to do. Um, check out the video
he's putting up. I'm putting some videos
up. We going to have some future stuff
coming, too. Um, we got that coming.
We're going to create a show with Rama
Ashan. Got to figure out what it's going
to look like. Um, cuz we want to also
introduce the futures market to y'all.
Other than that, man, go check out the
last post we put up. Hey, I need
everybody to do something, though.
I need everybody to go follow me, the
Wall Street Chopper YouTube. Um,
literally about to start putting a lot
of content over there. More content I
was doing, about to start going live
over there like I was doing on
Instagram. About to start going live
over like once or twice a week. Um, so
go follow that Wall Street Trapper
YouTube and put the notifications on.
Um, go do me a favor. We got 2500 people
in here right now that's left. Look, go
like all the last post. Go comment on
the last post. Let's get them up. I got
another post dropping tomorrow. Trying
to do like four, five drops a week and a
live. [music] Check that out. Go get
your merch. Everybody say your prayer
for George, man. George got a little
sick. He had a little situation going
on. I [music] told him you got to get
that diet right now. Um, go stream on
all platform. For all my travels and
travels and I got Lieutenant Casey in
the building tonight, y'all. You know
what I'm saying? Got Lieutenant Casey in
the building tonight. But other than
that, man, I love y'all. I appreciate
y'all. Same time, same place. Next week.
I appreciate y'all. Salute.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Hey,
hey, hey.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey, hey, hey. All
right. Hey
>> [music]